PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN CAPITAL ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH NONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE HERE WITH ME
ARE SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY
GLAZER MCGUIRE- MITCHELL
FEDERAL TROUBLED AND PAN. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
MOVED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND TO BE WE
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT FOUR ONE ZERO
THREE FOUR NINE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DAHLE ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT AN OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE. NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT WANT TO
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE AND YOU
DID AND. YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US HEAR
YOU. AND TO AVOID ACCUSED
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THE CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
DRESSING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. FOR BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT THE BILLS ON CONSENT
OUR ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB ELEVEN THIRTEEN EIGHT BYNUM
SIX AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
ITEM SEVEN AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON BUILT ESTABLISH
A QUORUM MEN CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA
ALL HERE LEYVA HERE- CHILL
ABOUT HERE THE TROUBLE CARE
CORTESE. DELHI GLAZER GLAZER
HERE MCGUIRE PAN HERE AND HERE.
THANK YOU ACORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED MEMBERS BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER HAS MOVED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BENEFIT SALUTE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND SENT SENATOR
LEYVA BY LEYVA AYE OCHO A BUG I
PHOTOBOOK FOR TENNESSEE. DALY
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN I
AM I WILL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ALL RIGHT LET'S
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR. BOB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THANK
YOU FOR BEING ON TIME HE'S
GOING TO BE PRESENTING AB.
TWENTY TWO PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU AB
CHAIR AND MAY. FOR THE OP
PRESENTE TWENTY TWO I'VE BEEN
THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE TALKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND WE THINK
THIS IS THE YEAR TO FINALLY
MAKE THIS HAPPEN MAKING A PRE
K. UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS IN
CALIFORNIA. A FIRST OF ALL I
THINK THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- HI WE
KNOW THAT EARLY EDUCATION. IS A
BIG DIFFERENCE MAKER IN MATTERS
FOR THE KIDS AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IMPACTS THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE LIGHTS FOR
SUCCESS AMONG OUR KIDS
IMPROVING SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. SCHOOL READINESS
AS WELL AS LONG TERM ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AS WELL AND AS WELL
AS ADDRESSES CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUES KIDS WHO GO TO EARLY AT
AND QUALITY PRE K. ARE LESS
LIKELY END UP IN OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. HOWEVER TOO
MANY FAMILIES STRUGGLE TO FIND
PRE K. IN CHILD CARE MASSIVE
WAITING LISTS. AND IF YOU CAN'T
OF. HAVE A SLOT TO GO SOMETIMES
WE KNOW THAT PRIVATE PRE K.
COST MORE THAN UC BERKELEY. SO
TOO MANY FAMILIES ARE NOT BOND
THE SUBSIDIZE LIST BECAUSE THEY
ARE SO CALLED A TO- RICH TO BE
ON THE SUBSIDIZE LIST BUT
THEY'RE TOO POOR TO PAY THE
TRUE AMOUNT OF PRE K. IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO WITH THIS BILL
AND WITH THE PACKAGE THAT WE
ARE PUTTING FORWARD THIS YEAR
IN THE BUDGET AND THROUGH OTHER
A BILL THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY. DO THIS
ONCE AND FOR ALL AND MAKE EASY
UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- THIS
BILL AB TWENTY TWO WILL JUST
WILL DO JUST THAT FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS GIVING EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA. A FREE YEAR OF
UNIVERSAL PRE K. THROUGH
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AS WE
CURRENTLY KNOW ONLY KIDS ARE
BORN IN THE FALL GET THIS FREE
YEAR OF TEEKAY. AND BY DOING
THIS WE WILL EXPECT SPENDING
ACCESS FOR ZERO THREE THREE FOR
THE KIDS TO COOK FOR THE SLOTS
pPRESCHOOL NEARLY HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS CURRENTLY SERVE
FOUR YEAR OLD AND STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. WE CAN USE
THOSE MONIES TO SHIFT TO SERVE
MORE ZERO THREE THREE
POPULATION WHICH IS HEARD
INSTANTLY MOUNTS BUILT THIS
COMMITTEE A FEW WEEKS AGO- THIS.
IT WILL BE TO REALLY. TACKLE
THE SCHOOL READINESS GAP AND
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE DIFFERENCE
WITH KIDS THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE TWO YEARS. OF
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION BEFORE
THEY ENTER KINDERGARTEN. AGAIN
THIS BILL IS PART OF A LARGER
EASY PACKAGES HERE THROUGH- THE
BUDGET AND LEGISLATION-
ELEMENTS OF THIS ARE EXPANDING.
SLOTS THROUGH TRANSITIONAL TKA
AND OUR STATE PRESCHOOL AND
CHILD CARE PROGRAM OVER HALF A
MILLION SLOTS. ARE SCHEDULED IN
OUR IN OUR BUDGET AND THE SCOTT
COMPANION LEGISLATION. AS WELL
AS RATE REFORM WHICH WE KNOW IS
THE PRIORITY OF YOURS- MADAM
CHAIR. IT'S ACTUALLY IN OUR
BUDGET RIGHT NOW THE MONEY THAT
WE HAVE NOT LANDED ON THIS.
SUBSEQUENT TRAILER BILL TO LOCK
IN HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT-
THOSE ARE ALL PART OF THE
OVERALL PUZZLE TO MAKE SURE THE
SYSTEM WORKS FOR EVERYBODY. SO
THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY NOT
JUST MAKE SURE WE GREEN LIGHT.
AT THE MAKE SURE WE DO IT WELL.
FOCUSING ON IMPLEMENTATION TO
MAKE SURE IT WORKS. FOR OUR
KIDS FOR OUR FAMILIES FOR OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND ALSO FOR
THE EXISTING CHILD CARE SYSTEM
SO WE HAVE WORKED HARD WITH THE
EASY FIELD. HAVE NOT FOUND A
HUNDRED PERCENT- YOU KNOW.
ALIGNMENT ON ALL THE ISSUES WE
ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE WE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- MAJOR
ISSUES TO MAKE SURE WE CAN.
EXPAND A PARENT CHOICE- IF
THEIR PARENTS ARE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE TO SERVE TO. GO TO A
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM FOR THEIR
FOUR YEAR OLD THEY CAN STAY IN
THAT PROGRAM JUST LIKE THEY CAN
DO. RIGHT NOW IF THEY'RE IN THE
ELIGIBLE FOR EXISTING T. K. WE
ALSO IN THIS BILL WORK TO MAKE
SURE THE PRINCIPALS AND
ADMINISTRATORS. HAVE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING AT TO
SUPPORT T. K. WE HAVE AN
EVALUATION PIECE TO MAKE SURE
WE FOCUS ON THE OUTCOMES AND
THE IMPACT ON OUR E. C.
COMMUNITY. AND LASTLY ONE OF
THE BIG THINGS WE'VE HEARD AS
WE LAUNCH T. K. IS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE IT. NOT JUST
A PLANNING YEAR WE ACTUALLY
ENGAGE WITH. LOCAL HEAD START
PROGRAMS LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
PROPER COMMUNICATION. AS WITH
LAUNCH T. K. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE GOING TO
BE AMENDING THIS BILL NEXT CAN.
TO THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WORKING WITH LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCIL OTHERS. TO
HAVE A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
FOCUS ON. TEEKAY EXPANSION. WE
ARE. COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE TO MAKE
SURE IT'S THE SUCCESSFUL.
IMPLEMENTATION BILL WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. AND I ASK THE
ARRIVAL THIS MORNING AND WITH
ME TODAY. ARE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM CONTANGO. A LOCAL PRE K.
PROVIDERS STATE PLEASE K.
PROVIDER IN CALIFORNIA IN CSEA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WILL GO
TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT WHICH I
BELIEVE IS HERE IN THE ROOM
WHICH IS KIND OF EXCITING THAT
WE'RE GETTING TO THAT POINT.
I'M LOOKING FOR MACHEL
KISSINGER AND JENNIFER CORDOVA
YOU MAY DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY. PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THE MICROPHONE. LAST. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING SHARE
LEYVA AND COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MICHELLE KISSINGER AND I'M A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
AND I SIT ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AT THE RAC DIRECTOR I
HAVE BEEN A CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE
FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS AND I'M A
PROUD EMPLOYEE OF THE MILPITAS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE
WE HAVE FIVE T. K. CLASSROOMS
SO WE CAN AFFORD IN OUR
DISTRICT CSE IS A CO SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY TWO WE BELIEVE IN
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WE SEE THE
DIFFERENCE AN EXTRA YEAR OF
KINDERGARTEN MAKES THE ACADEMIC
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS. I WANT
TO FOCUS MY TESTIMONY TODAY ON
ADDRESSING SOME WORKFORCE
CONCERNS WE REPRESENT PRESCHOOL
HEAD START TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS AS WELL AS MEMBERS IN
THE TEACHING KINDERGARTEN ONE
OF THE CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD IS
THAT UNIVERSAL T. K. WILL CROWD
OUT EXISTING PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
WE DO NOT BELIEVE UNIVERSAL T.
K. WILL DO THIS- OR CRIED OUT
EXISTING PROGRAMS OR DISPLACE
OUR MEMBERS INCREASE ONE HAD
STORED THERE TOO MANY. ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN ZERO THREE YOU CAN BE
A WILL BE SERVED BY PRESCHOOL
HEAD START ONE FOUR YEAR OLDS
ARE BEING SERVED BY T. K. THERE
IS NO SHORTAGE OF ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WHICH MEANS THERE IS
PLENTY OF WORK. IMPORTANT WORK
FOR MEMBERSHIP IN FACT MY
DISTRICT LIKE I SAID HAS A
WAITING LIST FOR OUR PRESCHOOL
HEAD START PROGRAMS. AB TWENTY
TWO IS GOING TO PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG
STUDENTS AND FOR MEMBERS
SPECIFICALLY THE LOW RATIO WILL
BENEFIT INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS
NEEDS AND REQUIRE THE
ASSISTANCE OF A PARA EDUCATOR.
AND THE TEACHER CLASSROOM THIS
WILL ADD ON ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXPERIENCED
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS TO
MOVE INTO A T. K. CLASSROOMS IF
THEY CHOOSE OR THEY CAN CHOOSE
TO STAY. IN THE PRESCHOOL OR
HEAD START PROGRAM EXPANDING TO
K. IS GOING TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES WE NOT ONLY
SUPPORT OUR MEMBERS IN THEIR
JOBS BUT WE ALSO SUPPORT
STUDENT OPPORTUNITIES. AND
STAFF ADVANCEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
THAT IMPROVE THE LIVELIHOODS OF
OUR MEMBERS AS MENTIONED I HAVE
WORKED IN PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
MANY YEARS. THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE IS REAL THE PARA
EDUCATOR SHORTAGE IS REAL BUT
THE WORK IS STILL THERE. THIS
IMPORTANT WORK STILL NEEDS TO
BE DONE OUR MEMBERS ARE THERE
TO FOSTER AND SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS ON THEIR ACADEMIC
JOURNEY WHAT T. K. BEING A
CRITICAL. COMPONENT IN THE
EARLY YEARS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND- PATIENCE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT I THINK UP AS
COURT- YOU HAVE TO MINUTES ALL.
A GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JENNIFER CORDOVA AND
I'M CURRENTLY A TEACHER AT
KIDDING AMOUNT THIS TO
PRESCHOOL CENTER AND DUBLIN I
HAVE ABOUT SIX YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN AND I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING ON MY BACHELOR'S AT
CINEMA STATE UNIVERSITY. I
SUPPORT EXPANSION IN
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE MANY
JOBS FOR TEACHERS WHO WANT
THEIR ASPIRATIONS FULFILLED I
SUPPORT UNIVERSAL TO K. BECAUSE
OF THE PRESCHOOL TEACHER TO
CHILDREN AGES THREE TO FIVE I
CAN SAY THAT MOST FOUR YEAR
OLDS ARE READY FOR AN ADVANCE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. THAT TAKE
A CUSTOMER BENEFIT THOSE FOUR
YEAR OLDS BECAUSE TEACHERS CAN
BETTER PREPARE THEM WHAT THE
MORE ADVANCED ACADEMIC LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. AND BETTER
ACTIVITIES FOR THEIR
DEVELOPMENTAL AGE GROUP. IF
THERE ARE MORE UNIVERSAL TO K.
PROGRAMS I WOULD WANT TO
FURTHER MY EDUCATION AND BECOME
ONE OF THOSE TWO K. TEACHERS.
AND PROVIDING A RAGING
ENVIRONMENT FOR CHILDREN AND
CREATE A HEALTHY LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WITH MORE PLAYFUL
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM.
AB TWENTY TWO MAKES IT MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE FOR
FAMILIES TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN
TO HIGH QUALITY PRE K. I LIVE
IN A LOW INCOME COMMUNITY AND
REALLY SEE THE BENEFITS OF
UNIVERSAL TO CARE FOR ALL THOSE
FAMILIES AS WELL. THE
UNIVERSITY CARE PROGRAM WHICH
WILL FILL AN EDUCATIONAL DREAM
OF MINE. TO HELP CHILDREN BY
GIVING NECESSARY ONE ON ONE
INTERACTIONS AND ALLOW ME TO
OBTAIN. A HIGHER SALARY FOR THE
HARD WORK THAT IS BEING. BEING
THAT. I FEEL THAT ALL TEACHERS
AT ANY GRADE LEVEL DESERVE TO
HAVE HIGHER PAY. I WOULD WANT
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF THOSE CHILDREN AND
WANT TO BE ABLE TO FINISH
SCHOOL. BE THE FIRST TO
GRADUATE FROM A FOUR UNIVERSITY
IN MY FAMILY. I KNOW FOR ME AS
A PRESCHOOL TEACHER. I'M NOT
NAY FOR THE MONEY. BUT FOR THE
EXPERIENCE ELEVEN JOY THAT I
GET TO SEE EVERY DAY WITH THEM
AT WORK. I SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TWO AS PART OF A STRONG
CERTIFIED EASY SYSTEM. THAT
SUPPORTS WORKING FAMILIES AND
CREATES PATHWAYS FOR THOSE
TEACHERS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW G TO ANY
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. PLEASE STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND STATE YOUR NAME
AND SUPPORT- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS ON THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SUPERINTENDENTS OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PATTING HER ON BEHALF OF EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIA A CO SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY LAWYER CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE ALL RIGHT LET ME JUST
SAY IS A CHAIR IT'S KIND OF FUN
TO HAVE PEOPLE IN PERSON SO
WELCOME. WE'RE NEVER GOING TO
GO TO OUR ROOM TWENTY FORTY IF
ANYONE IS IN THERE SEEING NO
ONE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATED YOU HAVE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO PLEASE
QUEUE THEM UP. CERTAINLY THOSE
IN SUPPORT IF YOU WISH TO. SEE
WHAT PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO NOW FOR US. FIRST WE GO
TO LINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OUR LADY UPON
REPRESENTING AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- FINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
MORNING I'M SURE MEMBERS
CHRISTY FUND AKA CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IT'S AMENDED
PETITION FOR DONNELLY OUT OF
FISCAL CONCERNS ONE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK IN THE BILL AS WELL
AS THE CREEK THAT. OUR CONCERNS
ARE MOSTLY RUN THE ISSUE THE
REVENGE OF PROP NINETY EIGHT WE
HAVE YET TO SEE THAT IN THE
NAME IN SUPPORT PLEASE SO WE
ARE LOOKING FOR THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEW LINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KATHY VAN OSTERN REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN- CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
TO FIND SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF EDUCATION
TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT OF BOTH.
THANK YOU- NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND. NINE THREE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND. FINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE ENSURE WE CAN BE
ACTIVISTS SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND. NINE SEVEN SEVEN YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND. SHARE SHOWING NO FURTHER
LINE'S QUEUING UP FOR SUPPORT
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITIONI HAVE TWO FOLKS
LISTED AS LEAD OPPOSITION
HEMONC CARDONA AND BECAUSE SHE
WAS INVOLVED WE AND WE WILL
START WITH WHO WHICHEVER OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED AND YOU
EACH HAVE. TWO MINUTES. AND. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MIKE
I'M GONNA FIND THAT MOTHER AN
EDUCATOR OF COLOR AN
EDUCATIONAL RESEARCHER DURING
THE SUMMER OF TWENTY NINETEEN I
WAS A SINGLE MOTHER TO A TWO
YEAR OLD UNEMPLOYED IN THE
MIDST OF COMPLETING MY
DOCTORATE DEGREE FROM UC
BERKELEY GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION OVER BURDEN OF NOT
HAVING STABLE CHILD CARE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK AND COMPLETE MY
DOCTORATE DEGREE WHICH
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED MY HEALTH I
CALLED MY LOCAL RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCY BANANAS EACH
DAY WITH THE HOPE THAT WOULD
MOVE UP THE WAITING LIST FOR
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE. AT THE
VERGE OF LOSING HOPE I WAS
BLESSED WITH HAVING A SPOT
AVAILABLE FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE FOR MY SPANISH CENTRAL BE
THAT BERKELEY HAVING AFFORDABLE
DEPENDABLE TAUGHT HER WAS
TRANSFORMATIONAL EACH KENTUCKY
THAT IS A UNIQUE PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT NOT ONLY PROVIDES
LOVING WARM AN EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT WHERE MY SON CAN
DRIVE BUT THEY ALSO PROVIDE
HOME COOKED MEALS AND ALL
TEACHERS BECAUSE SHE IS ONE OF
THE FEW AFFORDABLE BILINGUAL
PROGRAMS WERE MY FRIEND CAN
ATTEND MAINTAINING OUR FAMILIES
LANGUAGE AND CULTURE IS A MOST
IMPORTANT EACH HAVING ACCESS TO
ONE CONTINUOUS FULL TIME YOUR
LONG PROGRAM IN POWER NEED TO
RETURN TO TEACHING AT THE
COLLEGE LEVEL. EARN A PHD IN
EDUCATION FROM ONE OF THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS AND
RESTORE THE CENTERPIECE FROM
MORE OVER I AM CONFIDENT ABSENT
OF UNITES PROVIDING MY SON WITH
THE SUPPORT INTEREST GUILTY
THAT HE NEEDS TO BE READY FOR
KINDERGARTEN ATTY AB TWENTY TWO
WOULD LIMIT THE CHILD CARE
OPTIONS FOR THE SINGLE CURRENCY
AND WOMEN OF COLOR FOR WARRIORS
IN OUR COMMUNITY PASSED THE AB
TWENTY TWO WOULD SEND A MESSAGE
PARTICULARLY FOR BLACK AND
BROWN MOTHER THAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DON'T MATTER THAT
WE DON'T MATTER THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF. PARENTS ON THE
WAITING LIST FOR CHILD CARE.
RIGHT NOW GETTING AND MANY
CANNOT. IT OFFERING COST. FOUR
YEAR OLD WE- FROM A TRADITIONAL.
BASED IS YOU ARE BECAUSE THEY
WALKING SOUMS. THAT BASED CAR-
PROVIDES NOT WE ARE. WHO NORMAL
PARALYMPIC. SIMILARLY IN
DANGEROUSLY AS SOON. THAT A BIT
MARK WILL WORK FOR TWITTER AND
FOUND FROM DIVERSE BACK. SHE
SUCH A PRO HARPER THE CALL.
RATIONS PROJECT IN IN OUR.
ISLAND AGAINST OUR- OF COLOR IF
OUR DESIRES TRUE TO SEND THE
MESSAGE LOVE HONOR THE BIRTHDAY
CALL AND LANGUAGES OF. ON THE
NEED TO FOR BILLION INTO THE
BILL AN- DELIVER SYSTEM WITH
MORE COMMITTEE BASED. EARLY
CHAU YOU OFFICE LIKE CENTER
VIDAK OR THE A READ I YOU TO
VOTE NO ON TWENTY TWO AND
WORKED FOR TRULY UNIVERSE MIX
DELIVERY VERY EQUITABLE
PRESCHOOL AT THE EAST STOP. BIG
CARDONA WE WILL NOW TO MS AND
ALL WE YOU A LOT UNDER MINUTES
BECAUSE THE FIRST- PER WENT
OVER SO. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE A-
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE MONEY IS KEITH AND CAME
ABOUT HOW JOB CARE BE AND THAT.
AB TWENTY TWO AT BATS THE WORST
WORST DISTRICTS THE EXPERTISE-
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
AND PARENTS WILL TRY AND
BOLSTER AND FUNDING ON THE OF
OUR YOUNGEST. THEIR PARENTS
DESPERATE NEED CHILD CARE THAT
WE THEIR NEEDS AND CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE SACRIFICED
SO MUCH IN THEIR OWN LIVES
BECAUSE OF OUR REDUCE CHILD
CARE IS G. R. P. THE LOWEST
WAGES USUALLY WITH NO BENEFITS
WHAT PROVIDING LOVING CARE AND
EDUCATION TO OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN. UNIVERSAL TO
CONNECTING TO BE A LOT OF THE
LAND AND WILL BENEFIT MANY
CHILDREN BECAUSE THIS POINT
WE'RE REALLY DEBATING HOW BEST
TO IMPLEMENT IT WE HAVE
EXAMPLES ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
I'VE UNIVERSAL TEACHING
STRATEGIES THAT WORK AND THOSE
THAT DOLLARS I. JUST CRIED AB
TWENTY TWO DID NOT MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES NEED AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE MOST FOLLOWING IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF THE STRATEGY
PROJECT DON'T WORK THE WATER
UPTAKE OF PART A PART YEAR
STATE PRESCHOOL USUALLY ON L.
E. LED CAMPUS IT PROVIDES AMPLE
EVIDENCE THAT UNIVERSAL G. K.
AS DESCRIBED IN AB TWENTY TWO.
WILL NOT MEET AND MEET NEED A
PATH OF THE FAMILY TO BE A PART
OF CHILD CARE. OTHER STATES
HAVE PROVEN THAT INCLUDING TO
TAKE IN A MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM
LOOKS BACK. TO CHOOSE CREEK
COLO CHEEKY FOR THEIR CHILDREN
CAN ACCESS GRAHAM DOUBLE IDEA
SETTING. ASIDE FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOMES INTER'S WHATEVER'S
RIGHT. FOR THEIR CHILD AND
FAMILY. A TWENTY TWO THAT'S TO
RUSH CHILDREN ESPECIALLY BLACK.
OTHER CHILDREN OF COLOR YOU'LL
WHICH LEARNERS FOR YOU OLD. AND
A PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT. AS
BERKELEY ASH WILLIAMS. MANY AND
STUDENTS CONTROLLED BY. IN THE
PERJURY SYSTEM OPERATION ON.
AND W. LUGGAGE AGREES THAT MAKE
PEOPLE THAT THE CHILDREN
RESPECT. AND ONLY THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM AFTER THE- RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE AUTHORITY. IF TWO TWO
HIT PAUSE ON PLEDGES. BUT ALSO
A CO. PARENTS EARLY. EDUCATOR
AND ALL CHILD CARE. GOALS HE
TEACHER AT THAT. TO WORKING. ON
CREATING A TRULY YOU. AND
EQUITABLE SHE CAME SCHOOL. BUT
HE THE LIVERY AND CHILDREN THE-
WITHOUT. I THINK VERY MUCH TO
HAVE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE WHICH OF WHO. TO
OPPOSE. AB TWENTY TWO. SEEING
ONE WILL GO TO ROUTE FOUR. SEEN
NO ONE MISTER MARGARET OKAY YOU
OPEN LINES FOR ANYONE WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN ALL. TO AB TWENTY
PLEASE. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
LISA CHEN TO QUEUE UP IN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW FOR A- FIRST TO THE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
IS MELINDA FOR THE AND I CALL
IN FROM FOR LEARNING. IN OUR
COUNTY I THIS BILL. AND BY
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE THIS IS DAVE ABSOLUTE
SEQUEL I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
OTHER SUCCESSFUL UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS NATIONWIDE
HAVE INCLUDED COLD NEXT
DELIVERY WIDER WE'RE JUST
ASKING FOR NAME IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. BEIJING WE ARE CLOSER
THOUGH THANK YOU. NINE NINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD IN
THE MORNING WITH APOLOGIES FOR
BEING OUT OF ORDER MICHELLE
UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
SCHOOLS FOR SOUND FINANCE IN A
REPORT IT'S AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU- THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS BROADBAND A
CARBOXYL ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM AND
OPPOSITION EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENT TO CONTAIN COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- NINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS TATUM ACKER WITH
ANSWERED BY THERE'S A BEHALF OF
THE LEARNING CARE GROUP WHICH
IS THE SECOND LARGEST FOR
PROFIT CHILD CARE PROVIDER IN
NORTH AMERICA AND IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY HERE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEW NINE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEW GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS AARON HINTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF PARENT
PARTICIPATION NURSERY SCHOOL WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL ABOUT MIX
DELIVERY THANK YOU THANK YOU-
LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RANGA MORNING SHERIN SENATORS
THAT SAID SCOTT AYERS FROM THAT
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS LARGE
COUNTY REPRESENTING NEARLY
HUNDRED LOCATIONS IN ORANGE
COUNTY SERVICE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES- WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL WITHOUT A TRUE TO
MAKE DELIVERY SYSTEM. THANK YOU-
NINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN. MY NAME IS GET THREE LEYVA
CUTLER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
BY YEAH PROVIDING COMMUNITY
BASED OUT CARE TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND WE OPPOSE ALL THE
COMMUNITY BASED CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO AS YOU READ THE SAME
ON THE OPERATIONS SUPPORTERS OF
A COMMUNE CAL WE NEED
ENTERTAINMENT OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JANET RODRIGUEZ I
MEAN FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDER
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THEIR
IRRESPONSIBLE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEW HAMPSHIRE
SHOWING NO FURTHER LINED CUTE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR ART WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND- FIRST VIA.
FREESHEET THE OUTFITTERS-
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE- I THINK IT'S
LIKE A QUESTION IS THAT- YOU
KNOW WITH HER HEARING FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT- WHAT MAKES
DELIVERY SYSTEM I'M NOT SURE I
SEE IN THIS BILL HOW THIS
PREVENTS THAT IT'S NOT
MANDATORY RIGHT- BUT PERHAPS
YOU CAN CLARIFY THAT- BUT I
GUESS THE OTHER ISSUE IS ALSO-
YOU KNOW WE TALK EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE SYSTEM SO THAT IT
MAKES DELIVERY AND SO FORTH AND
WE HEARD EVEN SOME OF THE-
PROPONENTS TALK ABOUT- WELL
WITH FINANCING SO. I KNOW THAT
YOU ALSO HAVE TO THE CHAIR THE
EDUCATION SUB COMMITTEE FOR
BUDGET AND SIMPLY CAN YOU TO
SPEAK TO ME ABOUT- HOW THIS
FITS INTO THE OTHER PROPOSALS
IN THE BUDGET- IN TERMS OF THE
C. E. AND- ALSO- HOW DOES THIS
THE THAT AND PERHAPS ADDRESS
OPPONENTS CONCERNS ABOUT- MAKES
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR QUITE WAY
THEY'D BE CONCERNED OF WHAT
YOUR SPOTS THAT ON WHAT WHAT A
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WHEN.
LEAST FROM I UNDERSTAND THIS
BILL DOESN'T MANDATE SOMEONE
DAVID STILL HAVE A CHOICE RIGHT.
SO PERHAPS YOU CAN ADDRESS
THOSE POINTS. THANK YOU I THINKTHOSE ARE THE KEY IS. AND WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND SO WE'RE
HEARINGS TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL WRAP THIS UP AND HAVE A
TRAILER BILL HEARN IN THE
COMING DAYS BUT WE'RE HERE
TODAY. SO FIRST ON THE POLICY
ISSUES. FOR CHANGES HEART
CHANGING THE TRADITIONAL ORDER
OF THINGS IS COMPLICATED A LOT
OF THIS IS BUILT UPON TRUST.
RIGHT THIS IS A PACKAGE OF
THINK SO IF AB TWENTY TWO WAS
JUST SOLO. WE PROBABLY HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WITH YOU SEE HI I
PACKED I READILY ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT. BUT BY THE FACT THAT
WE'RE DRAMATICALLY INCREASING
SLOTS BY. YOU KNOW THIS AND
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL SLOTS
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW. PUBLICLY FUNDED SLOTS. AND
THE RATE IT BOB STRUCTURE.
BECAUSE THE CURRENT SYSTEM AS
WELL AS GIVES COMMITTEE IS.
HEARD BEFORE ANOTHER BILLS. IT
THAT THE PROGRAMS AREN'T
FINANCIALLY VIABLE- THE WORK
FIRST IT DOES NOT ARE NOT PAID
LIVING WAGES SO. THAT WE THINK
THIS IS PART OF AN OVERALL
PACKAGE- GETS THEBUDGET A
SECOND. BUT AS FAR AS NEXT
DELIVERY YOU KNOW WE THINK IT'S
STILL THERE IS THAT AS YOU SAID
IF AND IF A CHILD A FAMILY. IS
INCOME ELIGIBLE TODAY. THEY CAN
SEE WHAT THIS DO THEY CAN STILL
DO TO. A CENTER BASED PROGRAM
AS A FOIL THEY GONNA FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOME THEY CAN THAT
THEY CAN CURRENTLY DO THAT AND
WE'VE WE'RE CLARIFYING THAT. IN
THE BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
THE CASE. FURTHER THAT WE HAVE
NEXT DELIVERY FOR ZERO THREE
THREE SEVEN AND THIS. BY THE
FACT THAT WE ALL OF US IN A
MORE KIDS IN THE ALLEY EIGHT
SYSTEM THROUGH STATE THIRTY
THREE T. K. THERE'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CURRENT KIDS
IN STATE PRESCHOOL SYSTEM. THAT
WE CAN MOVE THOSE TO SERVE
THREE THREE THREE SO THAT IS A
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM. PLUS
FURTHER THROUGH THE BUDGET AND
THE COMPANION BILL SB FIFTY.
THERE'S GOING TO BE WRAPPED
AROUND THESE PROVIDERS CANCER
OF THOSE FOUR YEAR OLDS THAT
ARE ANTI K. SO WE THINK THERE
ARE MULTIPLE. WAYS TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AS FAR AS- THE
BUDGET. WITH THE WEEK WE VOTED
ON THE BUDGET AS YOU KNOW A
COUPLE DAYS AGO AND WE DID HAVE
MONEY IN THEIR- TAX IRONICALLY
TO PAY FOR RATE INCREASES BUT
NOT FOR TEA CAKE IS TK'S AND-
OUT YEAR. EXPENDITURE THIS JUST
THE START WE WERE JUST
AUTHORIZE IT. BUT THIS LOOMING
TRAILER BILL WHICH WERE STILL
NEGOTIATING THE SPEAKER IN THE
PROTON. THIS IS OUR TOP
PRIORITY. THERE ARE YOU KNOW
ARE MESSING WITH THE GOVERNOR
AS WE SPEAK- IT WILL HAVE IN
THERE. THE RAY. AND WHICH WE
CURRENTLY FIND OBJECT TO
INCREASE THAT THE EIGHTY EIGHTY
EIGHT PERCENTILE AND DRAMATIC
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN RATE
INCREASES. AND WE HAVE. OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW. CHILD
CARE AND STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
SO. WE HAVE THESE COMPONENTS IN
THERE. AND THE YOU KNOW I THINK
BY THE TIME THIS BILL IS HEARD
APPROPRIATIONS EARLIER IN THE
SUMMER. SO I'LL BE A RESULT BUT
A LOT OF THIS IS BASED UPON
TRUST AND LASTLY. A BIG PART OF
THE BILL AND WE'RE IS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS ONE YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- CAN ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND MAKE WE CAN BE. A
RISING BUT FOR EVERYBODY
BECAUSE I THINK THE BIGGEST
THING IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INVESTING FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR LITTLE SKITS IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH PRIOR GOVERNORS THIS
WASN'T AN OPPORTUNITY. SO THE
FACT THAT WE'RE- TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN DO. A MASSIVE
INVESTMENT AND RE HAULING ARE
YOU SEE PROGRAM. IS I THINK
HALF THE BATTLE THIS IS A PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT- ANSWER AND I
WOULD ALSO BIG NOTE DIE
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL IF IT
PASSES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL. THEN GO TO HUMAN SERVICES
FOR FURTHER VETTING- AS WELL SO.
OKAY THANK YOU JIM SO VERY MUCH.
THE CENTER PAN OTHER QUESTION
COM CONCERNS. OKAY WELL I HAVE
A COUPLE ARM COMMENTS- CENTER
TO SUMMER MCCARTY I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ALL OF THE
ASSEMBLY ARE ALL OF THE ALL OUR
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I DO
HAVE VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT
WE'RE PUTTING THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE IF WE DO NOT DO RATE
REFORM WHICH I CONTINUE TO BE
APPALLED THAT IT WAS NOT IN THE
BUDGET AFTER THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WERE OPEN. THE ENTIRE
TIME DURING THE PANDEMIC CARING
FOR OUR WORK MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE WHICH ARE OUR CHILDREN
IT WAS NOT IN THE BUDGET WE ARE
WORKING ON IT. BUT IT.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
SHOULD BE THE LAST THING WE'RE
WORKING ON GREAT REFORM IS THE
FIRST THING WE SHOULD BE
WORKING ON BECAUSE THAT COVERS
MOST OF OUR CHILDREN BACK IT'S
WORKING MOMS BACK TO WORK. WE
KNOW THAT WE LOST THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED CHILD CARE CENTERS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND THEY
MAY OR MAY NOT BE COMING BACK
IF WE DON'T DO RATE REFORM YES
I AGREE WITH YOU SOME REFORM
HAS BEEN DONE BUT THAT'S FOR
THE- WORKERS WHO ARE ORGANIZED
THAT ONLY COVERS 20% OF CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SLOTS MY NUMBERS
ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
YOURS I THINK FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND I THINK YOU'RE
CONFLATING THAT WITH. THE T. K.
SLOTS TRUE FOUGHT. OR THE
FOURTH OR FOURTH GRADER FOR
CHILD CARE THERE ARE A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND IN THE BUDGET
MOVING TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
OVER THREE YEARS. AND JUST TO
PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE FOR
PEOPLE BECAUSE I AT THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT BUT JUST IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND L. A.
COUNTY THERE IS A NEED OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
SLOTS. SO WE KNOW THAT OVER
THREE YEARS OF TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN THOUSAND SLOTS. WILL NOT
BE ENOUGH TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR CHILDREN AND OF WORKING
PARENTS. SO I JUST REALLY HOPE
THAT WE CAN GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE ARE NOT PRIORITIZING
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T HELP OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS. I THINK BACK
WHEN MY GIRLS WERE LITTLE I.
WENT BACK TO WORK WHEN THEY
WERE TWO YEARS OLD.
TRANSITIONAL WILL NOT HELP ME I
WOULD HAVE STAY HOME FOR TWO
MORE YEARS. WAITING FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IF
THERE WAS NOT HEALTH CARE
AVAILABLE TO ME AND MY
CHILDREN. SO LIKE I SAID I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS. WE WILL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. BUT
I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE CAN
GET TO A POINT IN THIS BUDGET
WHERE WE ARE TAKING CARE OF THE
WOMEN. THAT TOOK CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
AT THANK YOU FOR THE- FOR THE
DIALOGUE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT I KNOW WE HAVE.
BIPARTISAN AND STRONG INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE WE DO IT RIGHT
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THAT BACK
AND FORTH AND- I'M COMMITTED.
JUST LIKE YOU TO MAKING SURE
THIS IS A WIN WIN WIN FOR THE
KIDS AND FAMILIES OF CALIFORNIA
ASKEY RIVAL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEMBERS TO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN HAS MOVED THE BILL.
THE TWENTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HUMAN SERVICES. SENATOR
LEYVA. LEYVA AYE OCHO A BUG. A
TROUBLED NOT VOTING CORTESE ALL
RIGHT COURTESY I DALY. DALY NOT
VOTING GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN HI
CAN I. LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
AND MISTER MCCARTY. WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT BILL AND
THAT IS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA A. B. THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. WE GET IT ALL CLEANED UP
PLEASE PROCEED- AND. AND. AND
WELCOME. WELCOME THANK YOU. I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A. B.
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL ENSURE NON
ADMINISTRATIVE EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES SERVING IN POSITIONS
REQUIRING CERTIFICATION WILL
BECOME PERMANENT EMPLOYEES
FOLLOWING A PROBATIONARY PERIOD.
TODAY EXPERIENCE EDUCATORS IN
SMALLER SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
BEING DISMISSED. AND TERMINATED
FOR ARBITRATING ARBITRARY
REASONS WITHOUT WARNING. UNDER
CURRENT LAW ONLY CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES AND TEACHING
POSITIONS AT COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WITH AN AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE OF MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PUPILS CAN
ACHIEVE PERMANENT STATUS AFTER
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. THIS MEANS
THAT CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES IN
NON TEACHING POSITIONS DO NOT
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ATTAIN
PERMANENT STATUS. THIS POLICY
AFFECTS GROUPS OF CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS SCHOOL NURSES
ENGLISH LANGUAGE EDUCATORS
FOSTER YOUTH COUNSELORS AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
WORKING WITH SEVERELY DISABLED
STUDENTS AMONG OTHERS. IN THE
CASE OF A DISMISSAL PERMANENT
EMPLOYEE STATUS WOULD ALLOW
EMPLOYEES TO REQUEST A HEARING
BEFORE A COMMISSION ON
PROFESSIONAL COMPETENCE TO
DECIDE WHETHER THIS. THIS
DISMISSAL WAS APPROPRIATE
FURTHER A PERMANENT EMPLOYEE
HAS A RIGHT TO REQUEST A
HEARING DURING A REDUCTION IN
FORCE. UNFORTUNATELY SEVERAL
CLASSES OF EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
INAPPROPRIATE INAPPROPRIATELY
DENIED PERMANENT STATUS BASED
ON THE NEED TO CREATE FISCAL
SOLVENCY. OR IN ANTICIPATION
THAT THE NEEDS FOR SERVICES IN
THE FUTURE ARE IN SECURE. THIS
LACK OF PERMANENT STATUS IS
LEAD TO DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION AND FAVORITISM
WITHIN OUR SMALLER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THIS BILL WILL REMEDY
THE SITUATION TREATING ALL
CERTIFICATED EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES WITH DIGNITY RESPECT
AND THE PROFESSIONALISM THAT
THEY DESERVE. WITNESSES TODAY
ARE TWO ADULT EDUCATION
TEACHERS ELIZABETH KITCHEN AND
MATTHEW COKE. NEW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO YOUR LEAD
SUPPORT ON THIS KITCHEN AND MR
COGAN YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
MISS KITTIN PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH CATCHING AND I
TEACH ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE FOR EVANS ADULT SCHOOL
I HAVE BEEN TEACHING ESL SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND AGAIN IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I WAS LAID
OFF NOT BECAUSE OF MY
PERFORMANCE BUT BECAUSE OF
WORRIES ABOUT THE BUDGET. THEN
SOMEHOW MONEY WAS FOUND AND I
WAS RE HIRED. ABOUT ONE THIRD
OF US IN ADULT EDUCATION ARE
PERPETUALLY TEMPORARY.
REGARDLESS OF OUR PERFORMANCE
WE HAVE NO PATH TO PERMANENT
STATUS. WE ARE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM ANY OTHER
TEACHERS IN THE STATE OR THE
COUNTRY. SO WHY DO WE PUT UP
WITH IT. MANY OF US HAVE
MASTERS DEGREES AND COULD TEACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. BUT WE DO IT
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN OUR
STUDENTS AND WE BELIEVE AND
WHAT WE HAVE TO OFFER THEM. IN
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A YOUNG MAN IN A
WHEELCHAIR CAME INTO MY LEVEL
FIVE CLASS. HE HAD ALMOST BEEN
KILLED IN A TERRIBLE MOTORCYCLE
ACCIDENT. I SUGGESTED HE ENROLL
IN COMPUTER CLASS AT THE SAME
TIME AS ESL. THE PAST LEVEL
FIVE AND WHEN HE SHOWED UP IN
MY GYM CLASS IN LEVEL SIX IN
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY HE TOLD
ME HE WAS TAKING THE NEXT LEVEL
OF COMPUTER CLASS. AND LEARNING
PROGRAMMING. I AM SO PROUD OF
THIS YOUNG MAN. I FEEL HONORED
TO BE HIS TEACHER. BUT I'M ALSO
PROUD OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE ENGLISH AND AFFORDABLE
JOB TRAINING. WHERE ELSE COULD
HE LEARN SKILLS TO BE ABLE TO
BECOME INDEPENDENT AND SUPPORT
HIMSELF. MANY OF US ARE
TROUBLED AS WE WATCHED THE
GROWING GAP BETWEEN THE VERY
RICH AND THE VERY POOR IN THIS
COUNTRY AND WE FEEL HELPLESS TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT. AN ADULT
EDUCATION WE ARE DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. FOR
PROVIDING LOW COST
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIFE AND WORK
THEIR WAY OUT OF POVERTY. I
BELIEVE IN MY STUDENTS AND I
BELIEVE IN OUR PROGRAMS. NEAT
ONLY PROBLEM IS THAT MY
EMPLOYER DOES NOT BELIEVE IN ME
DOES NOT VALUE ME AND DOES NOT
GIVE ME JOB SECURITY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MR COGAN
YOUR UP NEXT YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND A HALF PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MATTHEW COGAN I'VE BEEN
AN ESL TEACHER WHO TWENTY YEARS
AND HAVEN'T COMMITTED TO HELP
SCHOOL- IN THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS MY DISTRICT
AND ACROSS THE STATE HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THE ISSUES ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL FOR MANY YEARS. FOR MORE
THAN TWO DECADES WE HAVE BEEN
ALARMED BY THE SHORTEST
SECONDARY TEACHERS IN CTD
CONTENT AREAS. THE NATION'S
EXPERIENCING THE BIGGEST WAVE
OF RETIREMENTS HAVEN'T THE
AVERAGE AGE OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL COURSES FORTY FIVE
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR EDUCATION. 20% OF
CARE TEACHERS ARE FIFTY FIVE
AND OLDER. LET ME BE EMPHATIC
WHEN I ANSWERED THAT THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OF CTE TEACHERS ACROSS
SUBJECT AREAS AND- THAT'S
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO ENACT
POLICIES THAT EXPAND C. P. YOU
MUST BE ABLE TO ENSURE. THAT
THERE ARE CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
TRAINING QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS.
AB THREE EIGHT EIGHT PROPOSAL A
FIX IN THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
TO STRENGTHEN CAREER PATHWAYS.
SPECIFIC CLASS C. AN ADULT THAT
TEACHERS. AB THREE EIGHT EIGHT
DOES NOT CHANGE THE AUTHORITY
OF ISTRICTS HAVE UNDER
EDUCATION CODE FOUR FOUR NINE
FOUR NINE TO DEVELOP PLANS TO
EVALUATE THEIR WORK FORCE NEEDS
AND MAKE DECISIONS MAY OFFER
PROBATIONARY PERMANENT OR
TEMPORARY CERTIFICATE
EMPLOYEES. FURTHER EDUCATION
CODE LOCAL NINE FIVE FIVE. HE'S
SERVING K. TWELVE CERTIFICATE-
PERSONNEL CLEARLY ALLOWS THE
ANNUAL LAYOFFS PROBATIONARY
INCOME AND PERMANENT
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES AB THREE
EIGHT EIGHT WILL NOT ALTER
THAT. AB THREE EIGHT DOES NOT
CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT THE
TIMELINE FOR MAKING DECISIONS
CONCERNING PERSONNEL CHANGES IN
MY HOUSE AB THREE EIGHT EIGHT
DOES NOT CHANGE THE AUTHORITY
THE DISTRICTS HAVE CONSTRAINED
LAOS. FOR PARTICULAR KINDS OF
SERVICES SERVICE SO IN THE CASE
WHERE CERTAIN COURSES NO LONGER
FIT IN THE DISTRICTS OF THE CPA
PLAN DISTRICTS HAMPTON TENURE
TO LAY OFF CERTIFICATE
EMPLOYEES WHOSE INSTRUCTIONAL
SERVICES ARE NO LONGER NEEDED.
AB THREE EIGHT DOES NOT CHANGE
THE FORTY THE DISTRICTS HAVE.
BEEN. L. A. RIVER TIME. PLEASE
WRAP UP. ALL RIGHT- NO OKAY AB
EIGHT EIGHT WOULD DRESS JUDGE
OF THE CASE APPEALS IN RULING
AGAINST- THE UNITED T. OF LOS
ANGELES KIM SUBMIT THAT THE
INTENT OF EDUCATION CODE FOR
FOUR NINE OH NINE CANNOT BE
CHANGED BY THE COURTS OKAY THE
RULES- YOU'RE WAY OVER TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
NOTED YOUR SUPPORT OKAY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PLEASE STEP UP TO
THE MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. CERTAINLY
ANTI TO APPEAR FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO IMMEDIATELY. FIRST WE GOT
A LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU. FIFTY FOUR- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND MORNING
MY NAME IS ISAAC GENESSEE I
TEACH MATHEMATICS SUBPLOT
SENTENCING COLLEGES CENTER BUT
BEEN THERE FOR THE LAST SIXTEEN
YEARS. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK EVERYONE TO
SUPPORT AB EIGHT THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. LIKE TO HAVE THANK YOU
SIR JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
THE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND. FIVE SIX
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND. IN
HIGH SCHOOL THE STATE PRESS
LOSS ON A LOCATION OF SENATE.
YOU'RE NOT OPEN. HELLO YES MY
NAME IS ANY THIRTY D. AND I
WORK FOR LA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS
AND I SUPPORT. SB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT- THE BOSTON OPERATIONS
CENTER. THANK YOU THANK NO NINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MONICA BROWN
STEEN I TEACH ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE AND ABRAM
FRIEDMAN OCCUPATIONAL CENTER IN
LOS ANGELES I'VE BEEN TEACHING
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS I AM IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. FOR TO. NINE
ONE ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ROBERT SHALL I'M AN
ADULT SCHOOL TEACHER WITH THREE
WATER EDUCATION. AND I SUPPORT
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU-
LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
MY NAME IS ROBERT YOUR GIPSON I
TEACH CYBERSECURITY I'VE BEEN
TEACHING FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS
FOR THE LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT AB
CREATING. THANK YOU- BUYING
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VICTORIA TRANGO I TEACH
CHARGING DOCUMENT SO OFTEN
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER AND I
SUPPORT. EIGHT EIGHT THREE
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU. NEW
LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DEBORAH ROWN I HAVE BEEN
TEACHING WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
APARTMENT ADULT ADS FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS I MEAN ACTING
WATERS IN FUNDING PREPARATION
CENTER AND I SUPPORT EIGHTY
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU-
BUYING FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MY NAME IS THOMAS
MCCLOSKEY I'M A CAREER EDUCATOR
HAVING TAUGHT TWENTY ONE YEARS
A BAND I WAS HIGH SCHOOL CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU-
NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MICHELLE COHEN I'VE BEEN
TEACHING FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
THE DAILY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
AND HIGH SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY
PLEASE SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU- BY
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JAMES FRANKLIN
AND I TEACH YOURSELF LEVEL JUNE
THREE OF THEM COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES- I SUPPORT AB THREE
EIGHT EIGHT AND ALL OF THE
CAREER TEACHERS THAT DESERVE
OUR SUPPORT- AND BLANK TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING MY NAME IS JOSH I COME
A TWENTY FIVE YEAR VETERAN WHO
CURRENTLY TEACHES ESL NINETY
COMPUTER APPS THAT EVEN CREAM
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER LOS ANGELES.
BUT I'M CALLING IN REPORT OF
MONEY NON TO PERMANENT STATUS
COLLEAGUES VOTE YES ON SB
THIRTY EIGHT THREE I THINK
THANK YOU- NINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEW YEAH MY
NAME IS KEVIN JORDAN AND I
TEACH ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE HERE AND- A LIFE AND
I'VE BEEN TEACHING FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS AND I AS OF
THIS DATE AND STILL DO NOT HAVE
PERMANENT FOUNDED BY MATTHEW TO
BE WORKED EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINE THREE FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JENNY SHACKLE BURGER AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
FIFTEEN YEARS AS A TEACHER AND
COUNSELOR IN HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA PROGRAM I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU- NINE ONE ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD- HELLO MY
NAME IS OKSANA FANCHER AND I'D
BE IT NOW IN THE YEAR THE
FUTURE OF FOR COUPLE AND
BARBERING AND- AND SUPPORT OR
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN THEY RECEIVE
THEIR GOVERNMENT. AT WORK I
WHAT YOU KNOW HOW DISTRICT AND
OR I THE- THE BILL. EVERYBODY
COULD BE ARE YOU SURE THANK YOU
SIR. ONE NINE FOUR SIX PLEASE
GO. GOOD MORNING HONOR ROLL
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROB OKAY
I'VE BEEN AN ADULT SCHOOL
TEACHER IN SOUTH BEACH CLUB AND
YOU'RE OVER TWENTY YEARS I
SUPPORT AB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
BECAUSE IT HELPS OUR TEACHERS
AND OUR STUDENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU- CLIENTS. FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OLIVIA
MORROW QUINN AND I TEACH AB DE
AGENCY RIDING WHAT ARE UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT- I'VE BEEN
TEACHING FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND
I THINK THE COURT SHOULD AB
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU.
RUIN ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
BRIAN HARPER I AM THE PLUMBING
AND DRAIN CLEANING INSTRUCTOR
AT MAXINE WATERS EMPLOYMENT
PREPARATION CENTER I'VE BEEN
TEACHING CLOSE TO FIVE YEARS I
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT AB
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEW. LINE ONE ZERO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND. NINE
ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND. STREAMLINED ONE ZERO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- HI MY NAME IS
ALEX PICKERING AYE PART VIDEO
PRODUCTION AND GRAPHIC DESIGN
FOR EASE LOS ANGELES
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER FOR ELEVEN
YEARS AND I SUPPORT AB THREE
EIGHT EIGHT. TO NINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME STAND TO CARLO AND I TEACH
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA SUBJECTS AS
WELL AS HIGH SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY
SUBJECTS AT VENICE SKILLS
CENTER LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I
AM ASKING YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
I SUPPORT AND FOR YOU TO
SUPPORT AND BOTH FOR A. B.
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT TO GET
PERMANENT STATUS TO TEACHERS ON
THE STERN STUDENTS THEY SERVE.
RUIN. NINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD MOST OF OUR BILLS ON HI I
AM KAREN JOHNSON A CULINARY
ARTS TEACHER SO OFTEN
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER I'VE BEEN
WITH THE L. A. U. N. D. FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
THREE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEW FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS STEPHEN ROSS FLAT
AND I TEACH ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE AND CITIZENSHIP
EVIDENCE COMMITTEE ADULT SCHOOL.
I'VE BEEN TEACHING WITH THE
DISTRICT FOR OVER TWENTY NINE
YEARS AND I STILL DO NOT HAVE
PERMANENT STATUS. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THIRTY EIGHT HI ARE
YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT. AB THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- NINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS PATRICK MEYER
HI HE TACKLE SUBJECTS IN THE
VENICE AREA FOR ELLIE- AT THE
AND I SUPPORT- A. B. THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT. TO FINE ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
MARTY SAID ASM A WELDINGTECHNOLOGY EDUCATOR AT EL
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT VS
WATSON OCCUPATIONAL CENTER AND
I AM IN STRONG. A REPORT OF AB
THREE EIGHT EIGHT ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE STUDENTS WE
SERVE HAVE A GOOD DAY THANK YOU
TO. THE. AND CHAIR SHOWING NO
FOR THE LINE'S CUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE
IN OPPOSITION I DO HAVE TO LEAD
OPPONENTS LISTED IS JULIE
DUNCAN AND MR RICHARD VARNEY MS
DUNCAN WILL START WITH YOU YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES- GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
JULIE DUNCAN AND I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF TRI VALLEY
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM
WHICH SERVES THE DEADLINE BUT
MORE VALLEY JOINT. CUSTODY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. I'M
HERE TODAY TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE EIGHT
EIGHT AND THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IT WILL HAVE ON OUR- KEY
PROGRAMS SUCH AS TRI VALLEY. I
AM NOT HERE TO A POINT OPPOSE
OUR TEACHERS HAVING ACCESS TO
DUE PROCESS NO WAY OUT PROCESS.
HOWEVER THIS BILL WILL CREATE
HUGE HURDLES THAT WILL PLACE AN
IMPOSSIBLE BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS
THAT WERE FORCED TO IMPLEMENT
LAYOFFS THAT RELIANCE. DORY AS
THE PRIMARY CONSIDERATION.
RATHER THAN SUCCESSFUL
INNOVATIVE AND INDUSTRY
RELEVANT PATHWAYS EACH EACH.
CURRENT STATURE ALLOWED OUR
PEACE TO ADAPT TO THE RCD
PATHWAYS ALWAYS THE CURRENT
RELEVANT TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
INDUSTRY CHANGES AFFECT WHAT
COURSES ARE OFFERED OR NOT
OFFERED BASED ON LOCAL
WORKFORCE THE- FOR THIS REASON
MY STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO.
CLASSIFIED JIM VIDEO GAME IN
OUR DESIGN SPORTS MEDICINE AND
CYBER SECURITY. IMPLEMENTING
INTO YOUR SENIORITY BASED
LAYOFFS WOULD FORCE US TO
RETAIN TEACHERS AND PROGRAMS
THAT MAY NOT HAVE LABOR MARKET
DEMAND. OR FOR WHICH THEY DON'T
HAVE THE PROPER EXPERTISE IN
TRAINING BECAUSE OF THE WAY ETT
CREDENTIALS ARE STRUCTURE. AS
AN EXAMPLE A TEACHER IN
DENTISTRY HAS THE EXACT SAME
THING TO CREATE CREDENTIAL AND
HELP FIND. AS A TEACHER TEACHER
SPORTS MEDICINE. BUT IF I NEED
TO IMPLEMENT A LAY OUT THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ME TO LAY
OUT BASED ON SENIORITY AND NOT
THE COURTS TO HAVE THE GREATER.
INDUSTRY DEMAND BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE EXACT SAME
CREDENTIALS. ARE- HE'S ALSO DO
NOT HAVE STABLE. DEDICATED
FUNDING WITH THE ELIMINATION OF
CATEGORICAL FUNDING OUR OF PEAS
RELY YEAR TO YEAR ON
COMPETITIVE GRANT. SUCH AS THE
C. T. INCENTIVE GRANT CASE
TWELVE STRONG WORKFORCE GRANT.
BOTH GRANT SUPPLEMENT OUR
FUNDING BUT DO NOT COVER A
FRACTION OF OUR CAR. AND AGAIN
OUR FUNDING IS COMPETITIVE AND
NOT GUARANTEED. OUR REMAINING
FUNDS OPERATE ARE DEPENDENT
YEAR TO YEAR UPON OUR MEMBER
DISTRICTS LOCAL DECISION. NOW
MORE THAN EVER OUR OPD TO
RETAIN THE CURRENT LAW THAT
GOVERNS OUR PROGRAM. FOR THESE
REASONS PLEASE CONSIDER THE
IMPACT EIGHTY THREE EIGHT EIGHT
WHAT HAPPENED R. P. PROGRAM.
THE PATHWAYS WE OFFER STUDENTS
SHOULD BE DICTATED BY LABOR
MARKET DEMAND NOT YOUR YOUR
TEACHERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS IS MISTER.
RICHARD OF ARMY PLEASE PROCEED.
I GET MORE MADAM CHAIR VICE
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE- MY
NAME IS. BARNEY CAME A COUNTY
SO. SCHOOLS SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THIS SCHOOL. AS THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SERVER. IF
YOU. SERVICE SUCH. S. YES YES
HE- DOES HE SAYS ORG. CAN WITH
IMPACT. EIGHTY THREE EIGHT WHAT
HAVE ON OUR STATE'S SMALLEST
MORE RURAL DISTRICTS. AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
MALL DISTRICTS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES RECRUITING. AND
RETAINING STAFF WITH THE
TRAINING CREDENTIALS AND
EXPERIENCE WE NEED. TO SERVE
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR COMMUNITY.
WE DEEPLY VALUE OUR TEACHING
WORKFORCE AS A CENTRAL PART OF
OUR SCHOOL. COMMUNITY BUT WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH ALLEGATIONS
OF THE SCIENCE WE MUST BE ABLE
TO. BE RESPONSIVE TO
FLUCTUATIONS DURING NORMAL. AND
WORKFORCE NEEDS. THAT ARE
BUDGETS DO NOT ALLOW US TO KEEP
A WORKFORCE BEYOND WHAT IS
NEEDED SIR OUR STUDENTS
ENROLLING AND ADDITIONALLY OUR
STATE'S SMALLEST ELEAZAR. YOU
DON'T HAVE THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. THE MAN
ON COSTLY LITIGATION AND WHAT
WE FIND OURSELVES IN THE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION. NEEDING
TO REDUCE OUR WORK MORNING
THERE IS A PRECEDENT.
THROUGHOUT THAT CODE TO READS
MOST SCHOOL DISTRICT-
DIFFERENTLY FOR EXAMPLE SMALL.
DISTRICTS ARE EXEMPT FROM THE
BUDGET RESERVE CAP RURAL
DISTRICTS WILL BE. EXEMPT FROM
THE LATE START TIME AND
NECESSARY SMALL SCHOOLS RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL. STATE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT OUR OPERATIONS. THIS IS
AN APPROPRIATE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF THE OPERATIONAL. PERSONNEL
AND BUDGETARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS FACE
AN ARCHITECT AT NAVIGATING. WE
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO LET US
BE GOOD STEWARDS OF THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE HAVE. NOW
AND TAT. HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
FOR YEARS. SOME FOR DECADES.
OVER THE- NOT THE OVER HUNDRED
THOUSAND WILL DISTRIBUTION LIST
ROUGHLY TWENTY PER NEWS ARE TO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHTY OR-
THIS REPRESENTS JUST BUT- TYPE
OF DISTRICT THAT WILL BE HARD
WITH THIS ONE FITS ALL OF WE
VALUE OUR TEACHERS BUT CANNOT.
FROM THE REALITIES OF WORKING
IN A STAGED STEPS BAR NEEDS RAP
AND WITHOUT NOTICE OF THE STATE
AND PERSON WE OFFER EXAM OUR
STATE SMALLEST EMPLOYER. OKAY
FIFTY WRAP UP OVER. TO BECAUSE
WE- CANNOT HOLD. EMPLOYER TO
THE SAN ROLES IN THE SAME
MORNING IN DAMAGE WE WERE. ASK
YOU VOTE ON THIS DAY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SIR
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THOSE
IN OPPOSITION HERE ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND
OPPOSITION PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU LEILANI ARGONAUT ON
BEHALF OF THE C. T. E. J. P. A.
COALITION AND OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF GOVERNOR FOR
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. VENTURA
MEMBERS JEFF PARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE HERE FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO ONE MISTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT BOTH OF THOSE TOLD I
MIGHT BE ASKED THE QUESTION.
CERTAINLY IF YOU WISH TO APPEAR
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
NEXT WEEK A LINE EIGHTY TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND. NINE
EIGHT TO EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO I'M SORRY BUT
THIS IS AN SUPPORT AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF US WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT THAT'S
FINE STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
SUPPORT. OKAY MY NAME IS ERICA
THE BETTER LATE THAN I AM AN
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHER WITH
TWENTY YEARS OF TEACHING
EXPERIENCE IN THE SWEETWATER
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT. I
KNOW THAT ADULT EDUCATION
CAPABLE SCHOOL THE STATE MA'AM
THAT'S ALL I NEED IS NAME IN
SUPPORT NEXT CALLER PLEASE-
NINE ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS THIS IS THEIR CLINICS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY. THANK YOU-
NINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I CAN MORNING SURE MEMBERS
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS SHELLY ADAMS
WITH PAUL DO YOU REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE POINT TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD- MY NAME IS NOT ENOUGH
EVERY DAY AND I'VE BEEN
TEACHING- CHILD DEVELOPMENT FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS- IN A 50%
pDISTRICT. GRAYSON FOR THE VIDEO
AS YOU CAN HEAR ALL TEACHERS
MA'AM THANK YOU NEED ALSO.
PROVIDER PLEASE- LINE ONE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS INTO A GUN OF AID
NOT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
MARIN NEAR THE END
SUPERINTENDENT FOR EAST SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY R. O. P. IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU- NINE ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD-
AND. MEMBERS CHRIS REAP ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY REPORTER
SO STATION I'M SORRY MADAM
CHAIR MY APOLOGIES NOT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MICHAEL
ALL SIZE OR WITH THE KERN
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF OUR
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS UNDER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHTY A
WE MUST OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS
THOMAS WORST- AND R. O. P.
TEACHER COLTON HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHING GRAPHIC COMMUNICATIONS
FOR TWENTY SIX PLUS YEARS AND
AYE OPPOSED AB THREE EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU- NINE ONE ONE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THREE
ORGANIZATIONS RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION CALITION. THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND MAKE YOUR.
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS WENDY MAKAN AND I AM
IN R. O. P. MENTAL HEALTH
TEACHER AT REDLANDS EAST VALLEY
HIGH SCHOOL AND I OPPOSED- NINE
ONE THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CAROL HIM
SUPERINTENDENT OF COASTLINE ROP
AND I OPPOSE AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU- NINE
ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WE ENJOY THE READ ON
THE HAPPENED CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATION
AND ACCORDING TO LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN RESPECT OPPOSITION EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NINE ONE THREE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS STEVE
ALL RIGHT ON MY TWENTY PLUS
YEAR ADULT SCHOOL AND TEACHER
TEACH MATH CURRENTLY AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THE ONE THIRTY
SEVENTY EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU.
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
WANNA AND I AM A PROUD TEACHER
OF THE BUILD SCHOOL SWEETWATER
UNION HIGH SCHOOL WITH OVER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
AND I SUPPORT. EIGHTY THREE
EIGHT EIGHT- VENTURE SHOWING NO
FOR DURING Q. FOR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. FEDERAL DOLLARS-
THANK YOU MADAM. CHAIR AND
THAT. THIS IS GOING TO REALLY
IMPACT OUR OUR RULES SCHOOLS
AND I LISTEN TO THE OPPOSITION
PARTY INTENTLY. AND I HEARD A
LOT OF YOU KNOW L. A. BASED
PEOPLE CALLING IN BUT THE RULE
I'M IS GONNA IMPACT FORTY FOUR.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN MY IN MY
AREA AND WE'RE TRYING TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE- IN. THE
ABILITY TO NOT BE ABLE TO BE
FLEXIBLE. I THINK IT'S REALLY
GOING TO IMPACT OUR OUR
SCHOOLS. AND DISADVANTAGED THE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T REALLY WORK.
IN VERY ABOUT AND- JUST TO GIVE
AN EXAMPLE THE GRADUATING. THE-
OF THE HIGH SCHOOL WHERE MY
SONS. AND DAUGHTER WENT TO
SCHOOL IS. FIFTY THREE
STUDENTS. TO TRY TO. WE GIVE
THE COURSES THAT THEY NEED THEY
HAVE TO BE FLEXIBLE AND SO I
DON'T SEE HOW THIS BILL IS
GOING TO- ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY CAN YOU
EXPLAIN HOW THAT WOULD WORK.
FOR THEM NUMBER THAT WITHOUT
THE PROPER FUNDING TO. SECURE
IT- MISTER DALI I- APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENT AND- AND POINTING
OUT- THE CHALLENGES TO TWO
SMALL A DISTRICTS. AND SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT CHALLENGE LA-
VERY MUCH. THAT AT THE SAME
TIME IF I MAY. UM JUST EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT AND MAYBE WE CAN YOU
KNOW CONTINUE TO DISCUSS- WE
DID HEAR. FROM TEACHERS I WANT
TO THANK THOSE TEACHERS WHO
TOOK THE TIME OUT OF THEIR DAY-
TO SPEAK. ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
IN NOW AND I'M NOT TAKING
ANYTHING AWAY. A MISTER
DARLING. SENATOR FROM WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AT THE CHALLENGES
TO TOO SMALL. A DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT TO
THE TEACHERS THAT CAME THIS
MORNING- THE TEACHERS LIKE-
ELIZABETH KITCHING MATIC COGAN.
AND THE MANY TEACHERS WE HEARD
FROM. I ALSO WAS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER LET THIRTY FOUR YEARS
IN THE IN THE CLASSROOM. AND
AND YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL-
FEEL A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO THE
TEACHERS IN THIS PAST YEAR- WHO
WHO WERE IN THE CLASSROOM OR
WERE TEACHING AT DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND THE- VERY-
CHALLENGING JOB THAT THEY DID
AND EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN- AND
WE SAY OFTEN THAT THAT THAT WE
RESPECT TEACHERS YOU KNOW WE
OFTEN SAY- AND THEN WE SAY THAT
WE RESPECT TEACHERS AND THE JOB
THAT THEY DO WE HEARD FROM
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHERS ESL
TEACHERS ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE TEACHERS I HAPPEN TO
HAVE TAUGHT BOTH THOSE
SUBJECTS. AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT A TEACHER WHO GOES AND
GOES TO- TEACH ADULTS TEACH
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
WORKING WITH WORKING ADULTS
WHO'VE WORKED THE WHOLE DAY AND
THEN COME BACK- AFTER HAVING
WORKED THE WHOLE DAY TO TRY TO
IMPROVE AND LEARN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE NONE OF THOSE TEACHERS
LIKE MYSELF WE'RE DOING THAT.
FOR THE MONEY THAT THEY WERE
PAID. THE AND IF WE GO BACK A
FEW YEARS WHEN WE WERE IN LOW
BUDGET- TIMES. AND ALL TEACHERS
ARE MANY TEACHERS WERE GETTING
WHAT THEY CALLED PINK SLIPS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE IN DANGER OF
BEING LAID OFF. AND THEY WERE
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS
OF TEACHERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHO WERE GIVEN THOSE PINK
SLIPS. ALONE AROUND THE
TEACHERS FELT DURING THOSE
YEARS BUT HERE YOU HAVE A GROUP
OF TEACHERS WHO ARE. EVERY YEAR
IN THAT SAME SITUATION WE HEARD
FROM THOSE TEACHERS WHO WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN TEACHING. YOU KNOW.
TEN YEARS FOURTEEN YEARS TWENTY
YEARS AND NEVER GET PERMANENT
STATUS SO I DON'T WANT TO.
DIMINISH YOUR CONCERN CENTER
DOLLY. ON SMALLER DISTRICTS BUT
AT THE SAME TIME I DO THINK
THAT IT IS- AND- YOU KNOW I'M
JUST A FULL JUSTIFIABLE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN WHERE
WE ALLOW. TEACHERS TO TEACH
WRAPS THE ROLE WORKING LIVES
AND BECAUSE OF THE IF THE-
WHERE THEY ARE TEACHING AND
WHAT SUBJECT THEY ARE TEACHING
THEY NEVER GET PERMANENT STATUS
SO THAT THAT IS WHY I HAVE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL. TO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE OBVIOUSLY WE HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM THE TEACHERS
THAT YOU TALK ABOUT. BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION STILL HAS TO RUN
THE SCHOOL AND START TO PROVIDE
THE CLASSES IN THE IN THE
ABILITY BILL TO AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A VERY SMALL. RULE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT HAS ALL THESE
MANDATES THAT THEY HAVE TO
MEET. THERE IS NO FLEXIBILITY
AT SOME POINT THERE'S NO THIS
IS TAKING AWAY THE ABILITY HAVE
FLEXIBILITY I'M NOT DISCOUNTING
THAT. LARGE SCHOOLS SCHOOLS CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MORE STUDENTS
MORE ADA BUT WHEN YOU'RE- IT.
REPRESENTING UP A WHOLE BUNCH
OF VERY SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE TRYING TO PROVIDE. THE
STUDENTS WITH A BROAD. AMOUNT
OF MANDATES IT'S THIS THIS BILL
IS GOING TO MAKE IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT AND THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THAT'S WHY THERE IS. A
CAR ABOUT- THERE IS HOPE.
BILITY TO HAVE THIS. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OR LESS NOT IN
THAT SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT YOU
NEED WITHIN THE BUDGET THAT
THEY ARE. TRYING TO BALANCE AT
THE SAME TIME. AND SO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HELP THE SITUATION I THINK IT'S
GONNA MAKE IT WORSE WHEN THEY
HAVE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
THOSE COURSES. MORE THOSE
STUDENTS WITH THE NEEDS THAT
THEY HAVE WHEN THEY'RE LOCKING
WHEN WE'RE LOCKING THEM INTO.
NEP THAT THEY THEN HAVE TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BALANCE
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE PART
THAT. IS THE FRUSTRATION FOR ME
ON MANY ISSUES IN GOVERNMENT IS
THAT WE SEE THAT. WE JUST
BLANKET LEE COVER AND WE DON'T
DIG INTO THE FACT THAT THERE'S
A ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
PROVIDE THE ALL THESE MANDATES
AND IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
ON SEVERAL LEVELS. ESPECIALLY
FOR SCHOOLS WHERE THEY'RE AT A
IS VERY LOW AND THEY DON'T HAVE
AND THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES TO
MEET. THE HI TERRY THAT THEY
HAVE TO MEET SO FOR I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY I'M HOPEFUL. THAT
THERE IS SOME SOLUTION THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUE WHERE
YOU HAVE TWENTY FIVE YEARS I
DID NOT HEAR THOSE PEOPLE
COMING FROM OUR DISTRICT I
HEARD IT COMING FROM VRY
POPULATED AREAS. THAT HAVE A
LOT OF STUDENTS IN THOSE AREAS
SO FOR THE VERY EXTREME RULE.
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT.
SOMETIMES DON'T EVEN HAVE THE-
FOLKS THAT. ARE EDUCATED TO BE
EVEN WHICH TEACHES CLASSES
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
PROCESSES SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY I APPRECIATE SEEING
YOU AND I AM GOING TO VOTE FOR
SOME OF YOUR OTHER BILLS TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY AND-
MADAM CHAIR IF I MIGHT YES- I
WOULD- PLEDGE. MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD WE MAY HAVE MORE
DISCUSSION. ON THE EFFECTS OF
SMALL DISTRICTS- YOU YOU HAVE
MY WORD ON THAT WE CAN WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THAT. THANK
ANY CENTER PAM. THANK YOU AND-
SUMMER MEDINA I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
DID NOTE THAT- YOU KNOWHE'LL
TALK ABOUT RETENTION AND- OF
COURSE THIS BILL THIS. DRESS IS
A RETENTION WHICH IS TRYING TO
HOW DO YOU RETAIN HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHERS BUT THERE'S ONE ISSUE
THAT'S BROUGHT BY OPPOSITION IS
HOPING THAT YOU COULD PERHAPS
ADDRESS. SO REALLY SOME OF THE
COURSES LIKE FEELS THE LEARNING
IT WAS NOTED THAT- THEY NEEDED
TO TRY TO MEET THE DEMAND- SO
THOSE I THINK THE TESTIMONY.
WAS ABOUT WELL WHAT HAPPENS IF
I HAVE A- NO WAY OUT ONE COURSE
THAT FOR INTO SKI AND I WITH
THE EXAM SORTS WORDS MATTER.
VERSE ABOUT THE THING ANY BUT
THE AND DAY AND SO THEY SAID
PROBLEM WOULD BE IF WE DECIDED
SOLELY BY SENIORITY. WE MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE ABLE TO RETAIN
THE PERSON TO ACTUALLY TO TEACH
THE- SUBJECT MATTER THAT WAS
MORE IN DEMAND BECAUSE THE
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT SUBJECT
MATTER SO IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S A
SIX CURRICULUM. BUT THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO. MEET THE NEEDS OF
ADULT LEARNERS OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS SO. HE PERHAPS JUST
SPEAK TO- SO I ACTUALLY AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD TRY TO TRY TO
GET. THESE TEACHERS OFF
PROBATION AND ONTO THEIR
PERMANENT STATUS. BUT CAN YOU
JUST SPEAK TO THE- HOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- AT OUR- MARK COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION WHATEVER TO
RUNNING THESE ROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY THESE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS- HOW THIS
WOULD WORK IN TERMS OF-
REDRESSING. THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE- SO BE ABLE TO RETAIN THE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY OF
SKILL SETS TO TEACH OUR- THE TO
SUBJECT MATTERS. THE KNOWLEDGE
BASE FOR THE SUBJECT MATTER SO
THAT THEY WOULD NEED. MURSI'S
DISHES AROUND SENIORITY LET.
THANK YOU- CENTER PAN FOR THE
QUESTION. AND- I WAS A SCHOOL
MEMBER KATE. SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER- COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUST.
AND WELL I UNDER THE CHALLENGE.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT SOMETIMES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ROOM- ALSO-
YOU KNOW MAKE THE ARGUMENT-
THAT WE CAN DO SOMETHING WHAT
PERTAINS TO TEACHERS BECAUSE OF
X. Y. AND Z. ROOM AND SO- EVEN
AS AS SENATOR DOLLY SAID YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY- I WOULD EXPECT.
AND I THINK WE HEARD FROM- FROM
MATTHEW KOGAN THAT THAT I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS BILL WOULD YOU
KNOW NOT ALLOW A TEACHER TO BE
RELEASED IF- THEIR COURSE WAS
NOT GOING TO BE BE OFFERED- AND
DOES THAT JUSTIFY- NOT GIVING A
PERMANENT STATUS TO ALL THE
TEACHERS KNEW SO I GUESS I'D
SAY IS THAT IT'S AGAIN I
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT WE SHOULD
GET READY JUST PROCESS. IT AND
I THINK IT'S- AND SO I ALSO PUT
THE BILL TO BUT- UPPER- YOUR
YOUR OFFICE COULD HELP CLARIFY.
HOW SCHOOL. DISTRICT ARE
SOPHISTICATION WOULD RESOLVE
THE ISSUE IN TERMS OF SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE AND- GIVEN
THAT AND- AND BE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE THE STAFF THAT WOULD HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO TEACH THOSE
SUBJECTS- IN IN THE EVENT THAT
YOU HAVE. UNFORTUNATELY
HOPEFULLY WE NEVER HAVE TO DO
THAT WE KNOW THAT FORTY DOES
HAPPEN THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE A
REDUCTION IN YOUR- WORK FOR SO-
SO THE PROVISION HONORED ALL OF
THAT THANK YOU. LOW
ARTIFICIALLY DUNCAN I WAS THE
ONE SPOKE TO THE- SUPPORT THAT
EXAMPLE IF YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO
ANSWER THAT I COULD DO THAT FOR
YOU. WELL I DID DIRECT THE
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL BUT I. AM ACTUALLY I THINK
I MIGHT BE ABLE TO HELP A
LITTLE BIT FROM TO YOUR POINT
SENATE ALL THE ABOUT THE MONEY-
THIS YEAR IN THIS BUDGET LCF
THE FUNDING IS GOING IS.
THROUGH THE ROOF SO THERE WILL
BE MORE MONEY. EVERY DISTRICT
BIG OR SMALL SO I THINK THAT
GOES TO PART OF YOUR ISSUE HOPE
MAYBE THAT HELPS A LITTLE BIT.
AND TO YOUR POINT- CENTER PAN
CURRENT LAW ALREADY ALLOWS. FOR
LAYOFFS BASED ON OTHER THINGS
OTHER THAN SENIORITY SUCH AS
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS SO SENIORITY
CERTAINLY COULD BE CONSIDERED
BUT IT IS NOT THE SOLE FACTOR
IN DETERMINING WHETHER SOMEONE
SHOULD BE LAID OFF I HOPE MAYBE
THAT HELPS BOTH OF YOU A LITTLE
BIT. NINE NINE MAY THOUGH YES
THEY DO YEARS WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES THIS. WILL
STILL BE IN EFFECT THAT'S
THAT'S MY- THAT IS CORRECT BUT
YOU COMPLAIN. WHEN YOU MONEY TO
FOR. ALL THE LONG BUT IF. WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU DO WHEN YOU HAVE A
BUDGET CRUNCH LOOK AT THIS YEAR.
MORE MONEY THAN EVER BUT- A FEW
YEARS NOW WILL BE THAT
SITUATION THEY'LL BE STUCK WITH
THIS. LAW NOT. BEING FLEXIBLE.
AND I WOULD I WOULD ARGUE
NGUYEN. IF WE HAVE THE MONEY WE
DON'T DO IT WE DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY WE DON'T DO IT WHEN IS
THE RIGHT TIME TO DO IT SELF
THAT'S JUST MY TWO CENTS. BUT
SENATOR OAKS USE ME ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES OF.
SENATOR CHAU BUG. GOOD MORNING.
A SIMILAR MEDINA GLAD TO SEE
YOU HERE CANADA. I DID HAVE A
QUESTION- WE DID HAVE A LOT OF
AT. THE BACK AND THEN INPUT
FROM CONCERNS FROM MY DISTRICT
FROM DISTRICT TWENTY THREE. AND
I NEEDED TO ASK YOU FIRST OF
ALL. AS A FORMER ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNER. TEACHER I
ABSOLUTELY VALUE OUR TEACHERS
WHO ARE. IN THE FIELD- I ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE DO HAVE AB
IT'S COOL BOARD MEMBER AS WELL
AS HE WE HAVE BE SURE QUITE A
BIT AND IN COMMON IN THAT
RESPECT- I ALSO. FROM THE
TEACHER'S PERSPECTIVE THEY
ALWAYS WANNA HE WANTS SECURITY
THAT'S YOU KNOW WE WILL
GRAVITATE TOWARD TOWARD THAT
SHE MINIATURE. ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE TO
MANAGE WE HAVE TO JUST AS A
BUSINESS WE HAVE TO BE-
REPAIRED. WE HAVE TO BE
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE WE HAVE TO
WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND WE KNOW THAT
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT IS ONLY. AS
SUCCESSFUL AS- HAS BEEN LOOK
FOR PROVIDE THE- ENVIRONMENT
WHERE WE PROVIDE THE- THE
RESOURCES AS WELL AS BE ABLE TO
RETAIN AND- KEEP OUR RETAIN AND
HIRE. ARE THE BEST QUALIFIED
TEACHERS. SO THAT IS A BENEFIT
TO OUR COMMUNITY TO OUR
CHILDREN- AND SO FORTH SO
THAT'S. THE CONTEXT IN WHICH
I'M WORKING WITH- I'M NOT A- I
KNOW TO ASK THE- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AS OF MARCH
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY OTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SO. I'M JUST KIND OF CURIOUS AS
IF YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS ANY OF THE CONCERNS OF
THE LOCAL DISTRICTS HAVE- THAT
ADDRESSED. AND MOST IMPORTANT
LET'S SEE THE LAST SET OF
AMENDMENTS- TO. JUST TRYING TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE
ADDRESSED ANY OTHER CONCERNS-
LOCALLY TO FOR THIS LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BECAUSE AB. AS
IS IT'S WRITTEN RIGHT NOW IT
WOULD BE DEVASTATING FOR MY FOR
MY DISTRICT- I THINK WE ARE
HEARING. LIVE KIND OF COMPETING
CONCERNS AND THAT. AT THE END
OF THE DAY. YOU KNOW WE VOTE.
AND WHICH WE THINK ARE THE THEM
THE MAYBE PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT COMPETING CONCERNS.
AS FAR AS THE AMENDMENTS YOUR
RIGHTS ARE B<c.cyan>- THERE HAVEN'T</c>
BEEN ANY TAKEN- BUT AS I SAID
TO CENTER DOLLY. I WOULD BE
HAPPY AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
CONTINUES TO ADDRESS CONCERNS-
BUT- AS AS CHAIR POINTS OUT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO. I
THINK THE RIGHT THING FOR
TEACHERS AND AT AND WITH THAT
I. WOULD ASK LAW FOR THEIR AYE
VOTE TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS CENTER
CORTESE. IF FIFTY AUTHORS
WILLING TO. AND WE KIND OF
COSTA RICA BECAME WILLING TO
JUST. ANSWER- SO A COUPLE VERY
DIRECT. REPORT QUESTIONS
ANYTHING THERE ANYTHING THE
BILL. S. TO THE- AS THE SMALLER
IT TWO HUNDRED EARLY FIRST
APPROACH TO THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN. RUBIACEAE EARLIER
TEMPORARY. IN THOSE DISTRICTS.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO THOSE
DISTRICTS WOULD STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY. OKAY OFF YEAH OFTEN
EARLY WHICH LOCATION ARE YOU
PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEES- AND IN
THE SENSE THAT THERE ARE FOR
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND AS FOR
ALL TEACHERS YES REALLY IS
THERE ANYTHING THE BILL THAT
EXTENDS THE RETIREMENT. DATES
FOR THESE TEACHERS THAT ARE THE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL OR WOULD
PRECLUDE- DISTRICTS INCLUDING
RURAL DISTRICTS FROM USING
GOLDEN HANDSHAKE OR OTHER TOOLS
TO. FACILITATE EARLY
RETIREMENTS NO- I DON'T HAVE
ANY DATA THAT RURAL DISTRICTS
ARE ANY DISTRICTS HAVE GIVEN ME
THAT INDICATE THAT- THOSE TOOLS
THAT YOU JUST RESPONDED TO THAT
ARE STILL AVAILABLE TO THEM IN
TERMS OF FLEXIBILITY OR NOT
ENOUGH. I HAVEN'T SEEN A CASE
WHERE RURAL SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES
THAT WERE ALL HIRED AT THE SAME
TIME THEY'RE ALL GOING TO BE
TENDERED- NONE OF WHICH ARE
PROVISIONALLY NONE OF WHICH ARE
TEMPORARY. IN NONE OF WHICH
ARE. ON THE RETIREMENT SCHEDULE
YOU KNOW LEAVING BY WAY OF
ATTRITION OR- FACILITATED EARLY
RETIREMENT SO I'M OF THE
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. IS SOMEBODY
WERE TO BRING ME- COMPELLING
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT. SOME OF
THE MANY OF THOSE RURAL
DISTRICTS LOCKED THEMSELVES
INTO- THE WEATHER WAS
APPROPRIATE OR NOT LOCKED
THEMSELVES INTO INFLEXIBLE
SITUATIONS FOR SOME REASON THAT.
DON'T MAKE THOSE TOOLS
AVAILABLE FOR THEM IN TERMS OF
FLEXIBILITY- I MIGHT CHANGE MY
MIND LATER ON I DON'T SEE THAT
HAPPENING. IT'S SO MANY DEPEND
ON WHAT I THINK I KNOW WHAT YOU
JUST ANSWERED RIGHT NOW TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD. THANK YOU
CENTER CRTESE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SAYING THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
APPRECIATE- EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
AND DIALOGUE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE. THANK YOU SIR DO
WE HAVE A MOTION- THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CORTESE'S MEN CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA HI
THEY'VE AYE OCHO ABODE NO. A
CHILL VIBE NO COURTESY HI FOR
TO THE AYE DELHI. DELHI NO
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN I CAN I.
WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT UP IS OUR FINAL BILL OF
THE DAY AND IT IS AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
WHEN EVERYTHING HAS BEEN
PROPERLY CLEANED. GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME GOOD MORNING. THE
NEW THE PLEASE GO AHEAD MORNING
THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOROUGH EVALUATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES-
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT. AB EIGHT
ONE FIVE WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE
THE SCHOOL NURSE SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA BY CLARIFYING
EXISTING LAW- BY STATING THAT
ELEAZAR. ARE AUTHORIZED TO
OFFER IN HOUSE SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS TO
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES. THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HIGHLIGHTED THE CRITICAL ROLE
NURSES PLAY IN SAFEGUARDING THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES
UNFORTUNATELY A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CHILDREN
ATTENDED SCHOOL WITHOUT A NURSE
PRESENT. CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF
THE WORST NURSE TO STUDENT
RATIOS IN THE COUNTRY WITH
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS
FOR EVERY SCHOOL NURSE. THE
SCHOOL NURSE SHORTAGE IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING AS
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS AMONG
STUDENTS SUCH AS CHILDHOOD
OBESITY AND ASTHMA CONTINUE TO
RISE WITHOUT SCHOOL NURSES NON
MEDICAL SCHOOL STAFF MUST
PROVIDE CRITICAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THAT STUDENTS NEED
INCLUDING ADMINISTERING INSULIN
MONITORING SIGNIFICANT
ALLERGIES AND ASSISTING
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A CANDIDATE
WHO WANTS TO BECOME A SCHOOL
NURSE MUST HOLD A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE- AND A NURSING LICENSE
IN ADDITION SCHOOL NURSE
CANDIDATES MUST COMPLETE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF COURSE WORK.
TO RECEIVE A CLEAR SCHOOL NURSE
SERVICES CREDENTIAL HOWEVER
ONLY FOR UNIVERSITIES IN THE
ENTIRE STATE CURRENTLY OFFER
PROGRAMS THAT CAN GRANT A CLEAR
SCHOOL NURSE SERVICES.
CREDENTIAL AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE
FIVE CREATES AN ADDITIONAL
PIPELINE FOR SCHOOL NURSE
CANDIDATES TO RECEIVE THIS
CREDENTIAL BY ALLOWING ELEAZAR
TO OFFER IN HOUSE CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS. THESE ALLEY A
SPONSORED PROGRAMS WOULD HAVE
TO BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ALLEY A
SPONSORED CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS TO MEET THE SAME
QUALITY STANDARDS AND RIGOR AS
THOSE EXPECTED OF POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
INSTITUTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
CURRENTLY OFFER THESE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS AT THIS
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO DR MARKEL NAVA WITH THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND TRISTEN BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN SO WE HAVE
YOUR LEAD SUPPORT ONE IN PERSON
ONE ON THE LINE WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE PERSON ON A LINE
MR- MARKETING OFTEN. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES- MORNING CHAIR
LEYVA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF MY NAME IS MARCO NAVA
AND I CURRENTLY SERVE AS
ADMINISTRATOR OF INDUCTION AND
CREDENTIALING IN THE HUMAN
RESOURCES DIVISION OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTEEN AT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS ST. LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED HAVE
COLLABORATED WITH EXISTING
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION
BASED SCHOOL URSE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS FOR
YEARS. OUR NURSES HAVE SERVED
AS PRESET PRECEPTORS FOR
STUDENT NURSES AS WELL AS FOR
OUR OWN SCHOOL NURSES SEEKING
TO EARN THEIR CLEAR SCHOOL
NURSE SERVICES CREDENTIAL
DESPITE OUR CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS. H. E. BASED
SCHOOL NURSE SERVICES
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS ISSUE ABOUT
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY CLEAR
CREDENTIALS EACH YEAR COMPARED
TO THE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIALS ISSUED
BY CTC. THIS DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PRELIMINARY AND CLEAR
CREDENTIALS SEEMS TO SUGGEST A
STATEWIDE ATTRITION PROBLEM
AMONG NEW SCHOOL NURSES THAT
MANIFESTS ITSELF WITHIN OUR L.
E. AGE. WE SURVEYED OUR ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY NURSES
CURRENTLY SERVING WITH A
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL. ONLY
20% OF THESE NURSES WERE
ENROLLED IN A CLEAR PROGRAM THE
OTHER 80% NOT ENROLLED EXPRESS
AN INTEREST IN CLEARING THEIR
CREDENTIALS IN AN ALLEY A BASE
PROGRAM THEY SAW IT AS AN
INCENTIVE TO CLEAR THEIR
CREDENTIALS AS WELL AS THE RISK
RETENTION STRATEGY. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED VIEWS THE PROVISIONS OF
AB EIGHT FIFTEEN AT CREATING AN
ALTERNATIVE OPTION TO BUT NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR EXISTING CLEAR
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS OFFERED
BY POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT FORESEE
FIFTY TO GRANT AN APPLICATION
FROM AN ALLEY A BASE PROGRAM IT
SIMPLY PROVIDES THE AUTHORITY
TO CONSIDER APPROVAL THIS BILL
DOES NOT MAKE LED BASED
PROGRAMS COMPULSORY IT GRAND
FINALE AB OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY
FOR CTC APPROVAL. THROUGHOUT
THE CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SCHOOL NURSES HAVE BEEN AMONG
THE FRONT LINE WORKERS SERVING
OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES.
PROVIDED COVERT NINETEEN
TESTING SCREENING TRACING AND
ADMINISTERING VACCINES. SCHOOL
NURSES WILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
BACK OF THE PANDA FIRST IN
TERMS HELPING. FEELING MANY
YEARS TO. FORTY THREE. LOS
ANGELES AS TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FIFTEEN AND URGES
YOUR YES VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK OU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
MISTER BROWN WILL GO. TO
UNITIVE EDUCATORS CAUSED BY
PROFESSIONALS GREAT TO BE BACK
AMONG YOU ALL. WE'RE VERY
EXCITED AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS BILL- IT WAS ONLY A
FEW YEARS AGO THAT I'M SURE YOU
SAW THE HEADLINES ACROSS THE
NATION READ FRED WAS TAKING-
BIG SWAP THAT WHAT THE OLD
GUARD WAS IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT FISCAL
ISSUES IT WAS ABOUT EQUITY FOR
STUDENTS. INCLUDING THEIR
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WE SEE
THAT THE PROLIFERATION OF
SCHOOL NURSES ACROSS OUR OUR
STATE. IS A HUGE CONCERN AND IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING BUT OF
COURSE I'M HERE TO SAY IT IN A
POST PANDEMIC WORLD WE ARE- SO
FOCUSED ON. BEING ABLE TO HAVE
MORE SCHOOLS WITH NURSES ON
SITE. AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OUT OF THE BOX- IDEA THAT AS
THE OTHER AND MY COLLEAGUE ON
THE ON THE LINE SAID. IS
SUPPLEMENTAL TO THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE OF GETTING.
CREDENTIALED NURSES ON TWO
CAMPUSES WE THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN HELP US
SPEED UP- THE CURRENT SYSTEM
UNDER THE SAME GUARDRAILS OF
QUALITY THAT ARE- YOU IMPOSE
CURRENTLY AND SO WE FIND THAT
THIS WILL HOPEFULLY PROLIFERATE
SCHOOL NURSES ON OUR CAMPUSES
AND HELP OUR STUDENTS
IMMENSELY. IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
HAD CFT VERY TRULY BELIEVE IN
IS HAVING ACCESS TO SCHOOL
NURSES EVERYWHERE SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL. FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS TO BE AUTHORING
THIS AND HAPPY TO BE WORKING
WITH MANAGEMENT AT LAUSD ON
THIS ONE IT'S BEEN A HUGE
CONCERN ESPECIALLY FOR LARGE
LOCAL THE UNITED TEACHERS OF
LOS ANGELES. BUT I HEAR IT FROM
ALL OF OUR LOCALS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE'S AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY IN ORIGINAL
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL GO TO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
PLEASED US FOR YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND SAN MARTIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO OTHER
FOLKS WISHING TO TESTIFY WILL
GOOD ROOM TWENTY FORTY SAYING
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF. AB EIGHT FIFTEEN PLEASE.
YOUR THANK YOU FOR THE- OF.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW US. FIRST WILL ALIGN.
MINUS- OPEN. THE MORNING THAT
AND SHE AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
MANY IS CORRECT THE KEY BEHALF
OF THE ASSIST OF. SCHOOL OF NAY
AND SUPPORT AB POINT FIVE THANK
YOU. NEW ACTUALLY ONLINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING ST NASHUA THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT AND FIND ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEW GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS RECEIVE BACK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FIFTEEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU- NINE ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND. ONE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WHAT A LOT OF
CHEN MEMBERS WILL ENSURE READ
ON BEHALF OF THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY OX MEDICATION. FIND FOUR
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KELLY MARTIN
ANIMAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND I DON'T CARE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE'S CUTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE LISTED AS
LEAD OPPOSITION BOTH CALLING
HIM ON THE PHONE LINES- IS
RACHEL MCCLANAHAN M. IS
SAMANTHA BLACKBURN IS MY
CALLAHAN WILL START WITH YOU.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS RACHEL
MCCLANAHAN AND I AM THE
COORDINATOR OF THE CALIPHATE
BULLETIN GOMEZ CREDENTIAL
PROGRAM AND A FORMER SCHOOL
MARCH. I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
FOR SCHOOL NURSES. THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONNECTED HAS
FINALLY BEEN MADE CLEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THIS
RECOGNITION THE BILL
DEMONSTRATES THAT BONUSES ARE
STILL EXPENDABLE ENOUGH TO BE
RELEGATED TO A CREDENTIAL
PROGRAM WITHIN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. RATHER THAN IN THE
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF NURSING
ALONGSIDE THEIR PEERS TRAINING
TO WORK IN THE ICU COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINICS AND BASICALLY
EVERYTHING ALL OTHER NURSING
SPECIALTY AREA. GONNA TO DO
DIFFERENT THINGS THE NIGHT THE
UNITED BUT THE PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATION IS NO LESS IMPORTANT.
IF WE VALUE THE WORK IS
COLLECTED AS MUCH AS WE VALUE
THE WORK OF ICE AND ICU NURSES
OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH NURSE
THERE. WHY WOULD WE NOT COMMIT
TO ENSURING THAT THEY RECEIVE
THE SAME HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION. DON'T CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. THEY SERVE ALSO
DESERVE BEST. HELLO THAN TO
EDUCATE IN AND A BE MARCH. BY
APPROACH THAT IS LIMITED AND
SCOPE BECAUSE IT WILL NOT BE
BASS ON OVER. NATIONAL
EDUCATION STANDARDS. TRUE IT
MIGHT NEED THE BASIC
CREDENTIALING CRITERIA THAT
STUDENTS ATTENDING UNIVERSITY
PROGRAMS WE SEE MORE THAN JUST
A FEW CLASSES TO EARN A
CREDENTIAL. UNIVERSITY EDUCATED
NURSES ARE PART OF THE VAST
STRUCTURE A STANDARDIZED.
EVIDENCE BASED PROFESSIONAL
NURSING PROGRAM. ANY PROGRAM
NURSES INCLUDING FULL NURSES
ARE SPECIFICALLY TRAINED ON HOW
TO PROVIDE CARE TO MEET LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL HEALTH IN
EQUITY GOAL SET FORTH BY THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF MEDICINE
AND OTHERS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
HELP THE NURSING SHORTAGE IF
SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR A LOWER
QUALITY EDUCATION PROGRAM
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON ALLEY
EIGHT. PLEASE SUPPORT THE
PROFESSION AND DISCIPLINE OF
NURSING AND SCHOOL NURSES. BY
KEEPING ALL NURSING EDUCATION.
IN THE UNIVERSITY WHERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO BLACK
PLEASE. WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
BLACKBURN. AND I COORDINATE THE
SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
AT SACRAMENTO STATE. WELL I
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS
EXPLORING WAYS TO SUPPORT WELL
NOTHING. AB EIGHT FIFTEEN IT'S
NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO DO SO. AND
LEN OWNER'S CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
WILL LIMIT IT DANCE. AND PLACE
A CEILING ON THE SALARY
INCREASE. A SCHOOL NURSE UNDER
THE L. E. A. PROPOSAL WOULD NOT
GENERATE COLLEGE UNIT. PAUL
FULLER SAYS ARE ENCOURAGE ALL
NURSES ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE TO EARN A
MASTER'S DEGREE OR HIGHER THIS
WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE TO AN
ALLEY A PROGRAM. MANY LA A PAIN
SCALES REQUIRE COLLEGE UNIT
INCREASE OR THE BAND ALONG WITH
CANCELLED YEAH. WITHOUT THE
NECESSARY COLLEGE IN A
CUSTOMER'S RECEIVING THEIR
CREDENTIALS WITH THE L. A.
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM WOULD BE
LIMITED IN THE EARNING
POTENTIAL. ALSO WE ALREADY HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO SERVE ALL YOUR
CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES AND OUR
CAPACITY IS GROWING. THERE
ISN'T A BACKLOG FOR A
WEIGHTLESS ENTER ANY OF THE
THREE THE US IS GONNA THINK
PROGRAM. ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS
CATER TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
CANDIDATES BY OFFERING VIRTUAL
COURSE. COURSE OFFERINGS AND
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF IN PERSON
DATE. THE INCREASE ACCESS
ACROSS THE STATE. CURRENTLY SAN
FRANCISCO STATE IS A FINE TO
THE CDC TO OPEN THE BORDERS
PROVINCIAL PROGRAM STARTING IN
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
START WITH THE START OF ABOUT
THIRTY STUDENTS AND CAPACITY TO
UPSCALE AS PART. LAST WE ALL OF
THAT ALLEY NEED MORE SCHOOL IN
OUR WHO ARE BETTER SUPPORT.
HOWEVER A ONE OFF PROGRAM THAT
THERE'S A SINGLE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS NOT BENEFICIAL. TO
EITHER THE SCHOOL NURSING
CANDIDATES. OR TO THE NURSING
PROFESSION AS A WHOLE.
THEREFORE WE ENCOURAGE ELLIE IS
TO PARTNER WITH THE CSU AND
DEVELOP PROGRAMS THAT RECRUIT
NEW CANDIDATES THAT RESULT IN
SCHOOL NURSING CANDIDATES.
HAVING CAREER ADVANCEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. HAVING A STRONG
WELL EDUCATED AND SUSTAINABLE
WORK FOR. AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVING NURSING CARE.
THAT THEY CONTRACT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO HAVE ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TO A THREE
WITCHES WHO WISHES TO SUPPORT-
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION SAYING
NONE. OF THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEN NONE MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE KEEP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHT FIFTEEN PLEASE.
CERTAINLY HAD NO SET UP
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO- FIND SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES THIS IS LYDIA BORN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION I AM WE
CONCUR WITH THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WE ARE ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE ON AB EIGHT FIFTEEN-
THANK YOU- AFTER SHOWING NO FOR
THE LIGHTS CUTE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. A CENTER PAM.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND SOME
MEMBER RIVAS FIRST OF ALL- SHE
DEBTS AND- THAT'S A SHARE YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT THE- SHORTAGE OF
SCHOOL NURSES IN FACT- IN MY
CAREER AS A PEDIATRICIAN
ACTUALLY SERVED AS THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANT FOR- SCHOOL DISTRICT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO- SENTIMENTS
A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ONE
THE LARGER ONES. VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE SCHOOL NURSES AND
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS- AND- THIS
IS SO- HIMSELF AND NOT ON MY BY
THE WAY I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE SCHOOL HEALTH- TRANSACTION
FOR AMERICA PEDIATRIC SO IT'S A
PARTICULAR INTEREST OF MINE.
AND I GUESS- I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS AND I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT YOUR BILL NOT
WITH YOUR GOAL BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE AND I KNOW YOU WANT
TO TRY TO. CALL BUT- I GUESS
ONE THE QUESTIONS I HAVE IS
THAT- BASICALLY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE AN ALLEY A AND I AND I
DON'T KNOW THERE'S MORE AND L.
A. U. S. D.'S PLANE TO DO THIS
OR NOT- SO I WAS JUST LAS
ENCINAS OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT
ARE INTERESTED IN DOING THIS.
IS A REAL WHAT'S THE ROLE OF
THE COMMISSION COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING CENTER
STAND THE THEY'RE THE ONLY ONES
WHO HAVE TO SIGN OFF ON THE
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY
OF THE PROGRAM. YES THIS OF THE
CTC THE TEACHERS CREIGHTON-
APPROVES THESE PROGRAMS AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS JUST
ALLOW THEM. TO CONSIDER- A
SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
THAT IS BASED OUT OF AN ALLEY
A- WHILE THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY LOS ANGELES UNIFIED- WE HAVE
OTHER- COUNTY. OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT INCLUDING
HUMBOLDT COUNTY SHASTA COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY HAVE PLANS TO DO THIS
BUT THEY HAVE SUPPORTED THIS
IS SO I THINK ONE OF THINGS I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME SORT OF
COMPOUND IS SORT OF CONFLATING
A COUPLE THINGS SO YES SCHOOL
NURSES PRACTICE IN SCHOOLS AND
AN EDUCATIONAL SETTING- BUT
THEIR MAIN ROLE THERE IS
ACTUALLY. HEALTH I MEAN THE
HEALTH SERVICES NOT THE
EDUCATION SO. WELL CERTAINLY
SOMETIMES SCHOOL NURSES CAN BE
INVOLVED IN TEACHING THINGS
STUDENTS AND SO FORTH. SO I
THINK THE ON THE COMMISSION
TEACHER CREDENTIALING WHICH IS
VERY FOCUSED ON EDUCATORS AND
EDUCATION STANDARDS WHICH IS
THEIR ROLE NOT SURE IS THE
RIGHT BODY BECAUSE IT'S NOT
REALLY ADDRESSING THE HEALTH
PART SIDE OF THINGS THEY'RE NOT
EXPERTS AND HEALTHCARE EXPERTS
IN EDUCATION. EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS- A JUST TELL YOU FROM
MY EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
SCHOOL NURSES- AS A MEDICAL
CONSULTANT. SCHOOL NURSES HAVE
TO TAKE CARE OF FAIRLY CAN END
UP TAKING CARE VERY COMPLEX
PATIENTS SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT YOU HAVE A CHILD THAT OF
COURSE EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT
EVERY CHILD HAS A RIGHT TO AN
EDUCATION. SO THEY'RE IN THE
SCHOOL DEPRIVE IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. THEY MAY NEED
SOMEONE TO FEED THEM THROUGH A
G. TWO MAY NEED TO HAVE OTHERS-
K. AND SO FORTH. AND FOR WHEN I
WAS WORKING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WORKING THE SCHOOL
NURSES OFTENTIMES THAT WAS.
WHAT I DID WAS. TRY TO GIVE
THEM ADVICE ON HOW TO MANAGE
THESE PATIENTS BECAUSE-
ESSENTIALLY THE SCHOOL NURSE
THAT IS FAIRLY INDEPENDENT I
MEAN FACTORED THE EXPERT SO
WE'LL BUT TIMES. THE OTHER
STAFF GO TO THEM AND ASK THEM
HOW HOW TO HANDLE DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT HEALTH ISSUES SO IT'S
NOT SIMPLY- WHICH OUT AS A
HEADACHE HERE'S- A TYLENOL AND
I WAS WATCHING MY OFFICE AND WE
ACTUALLY CAN DO FAIRLY
SOPHISTICATED THEY HAVE TO. THE
HANDLE FAIRLY SOPHISTICATED
THINGS. AND MY CONCERN IS THAT-
WERE GOING TO CREATE A
SITUATION WHERE- CERTAINLY. YOU
KNOW THAT NURSES- WHO ARE INTO
IN DOING- ARE VERY CAREFUL WHY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT THAT
WAS TAKEN TO RELEASE REQUIRED
BACHELORS DEGREE. BUT IN FACT
MANY SCHOOL NURSES ACTUALLY DO
HAVE MASTERS DEGREES BECAUSE-
THE AMOUNT OF- SKILL THAT IT
TAKES ACTUALLY MANAGE THESE.
SOMEWHAT COMPLEX PATIENTS AND
ALSO TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ASPECT AS WELL BECAUSE YOU'RE
KIND OF LIKE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSON FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT FOR
THE SCHOOL AND SCHOOL DISTRICT
ARE CONFLICTING MULTIPLE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOR. SCHOOL NURSES. SO I
AM CONCERNED THAT THIS- THAT BY
HAVING THE CTC AND I ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT- THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TESTIFYING FOR WERE LIKE HUMAN
RESOURCES ADMINISTRATOR CITING
HERE PEOPLE FROM THE SCHOOL
HEALTH COMMUNITY SAYING HEY
THIS IS. THIS IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO ABOUT GETTING MORE SCHOOL
NURSES- BY HERE IS THAT FROM
THE SCHOOL HEALTH COMMUNITY
THAT WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE STANDARDS AND- ARE WE
GONNA HAVE SCHOOL NURSES NOW I
UNDERSTAND WE DON'T HAVE THE
SCHOOL NURSES WE HAVE SCHOOL
STAFF EVEN THROWN AT THIS
POSITION BUT SCHOOL NURSES FROM
THE POSITION WHERE. THEY THE
WHERE WE'RE BASICALLY- HILLS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE W. F.
THREE DIFFICULT POSITION
BECAUSE- AGAIN THE STANDARDS
ARE APPLIED TO THEM ARE NOT
REALLY STANDARDS RELATED
NURSING THEIR STANDARDS RELATED
TO. YOU KNOW EDUCATION- AND SO
WHILE THEY ARE PRACTICING AN
EDUCATIONAL SETTING I THINK
THAT I WOULD PREFER THAT IF WE
WOULD HAVE AN ENTITY. THAT WAS
FOCUSED ON NURSING. BE THE ONE
THAT HAS TO SIGN OFF ON
WHATEVER PROGRAM IS. YOU KNOW
SUFFICIENT AND SO I GET THAT
YOU DID HAVE LANGUAGE SAYING
WELL THE CDC HAS TO ON THE ON
THE PRICE THE SAME STANDARDS
BUT THEY'RE NOT REALLY IN A
GOOD PLACE TO INTERPRET WHETHER
DISPERSED THAT THAT OTHER.
PROGRAM ACTUALLY. HAD THE RIGHT
STANDARDS ARE NOT A- NURSING-
AS A STANDARDS ORGANIZATION
WRITER AND EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS ORGANIZATION. SO
PERHAPS- SO ANYWAY I SO I DO
HAVE MY CONCERNS I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAVE SOME ANSWERS TO
THAT- WITH YOU I ANSWER IT NOW
OR TO CLOSE- BUT- IT YOU KNOW I
AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT. THE THAT. THE CDC IS
THE MAIN BACKSTOPS TO BE SURE
THAT THESE NURSES MEET THE
STANDARD AND- AND SO. FORTY ONE
APPEALS TO SUPPORT BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU CAN EXCLUDE PROCEED
WITH THE SENATE THANK YOU FOR.
YOUR CONCERNS I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT- THE SCHOOL NAY.
CURRENTLY THE CTC. AS EVEN
TODAY APPROVED THE SCHOOL
NURSING CREDENTIAL. THIS BILL
IS NOT CHANGING THAT I KNOW YOU
YOU EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE CTC BEING THE ENTITY.
TO APPROVE THESE PROGRAMS WERE
RIGHT NOW LIKE WHAT WAS
MENTIONED SAN FRANCISCO STATE
WANTS TO CREATE A NEW PROGRAM.
THE CTC. IS GOING TO APPROVE
THE SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIAL-
THE SCHOOL NURSE CANDIDATES
ALL. ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. AND A
NURSING LICENSE WHICH HAS YOU
KNOW THAT IS AN ENTITY. THE IN
OUR STATE THAT APPROVES THEIR
QUALIFICATION. BASED ON THE
NURSE SEEN AND MATTER. OF
REQUIREMENTS WRITER- SKILLS
THAT THEY HAVE. THIS PROGRAM IS
JUST AN ADDITIONAL YEAR FOR A
NURSE TO PRACTICE ALREADY A
LICENSED NURSE. TO PRACTICE IN
A SCHOOL SETTING- THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE PROPOSING
TODAY. THE CTC ALREADY APPROVED
THAT CREDENTIAL FOR ANY
INSTITUTION- A POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTION IN OUR STATE. OF
THE SO WE ARE NOT CHANGING NOW
ALL WE'RE DOING IS. ALLOWING
THE CTC TO CONSIDER. AN
APPLICATION FROM AN ALLEY EIGHT
OF THE CTC WILL APPLY THE SAME
QUALITY STANDARDS- AS IT
CURRENTLY DOES TO EVALUATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. THEY CAN
DENY THE APPLICATION. APPROVED
IT WOULD BE UP TO THE C. T. C.
USING THE EXACT SAME STANDARDS
THAT THEY WOULD USE ON CAL
STATE FULLERTON- SAN FRANCISCO
DATE SAN FRANCISCO STATE AND
OTHER- UNIVERSITIES IN OUR
STATE. I AM I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT CLEARS IT UP I JUST WANTED
TO BE CLEAR- THAT THIS IS NOT A
NURSING LICENSE RIGHT THIS IS
THE SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIAL
THAT IS JUST ONE YEAR. IN
ADDITION TO THE BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AND THEN LICENSE- THAT
AN INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL THERE'S
CANDIDATES ALREADY HAS WHEN
THEY ENTER. THE NET AND
APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION
AND I KNOW YOU'VE YOU KNOW
YOU'VE WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS
SO- I GUESS FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN AND
OTHERS WORKED PRETTY CLOSELY
SCHOOL NURSES AND THE FACT THA
SCHOOL NURSING ORGANS YOU KNOW
SCHOOL HEALTH FOLKS ARE
OPPOSED. I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN
THINK ABOUT IN ADDITION TO THE
C. T. C. BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO. YELL FOR
READY GOOD REASONS IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER SCHOOL NURSES THEY HAVE.
AN EIGHT YEAR AGREED THEY DO
HAVE A LICENSE- FROM THE
NURSING BOARD BUT PRIDE MORE
SPECIFICALLY E. JUST I DON'T
KNOW IT'S REQUIRES THEM TO HAVE
SOME SPECIALTY IN SCHOOL
NURSING- IN THAT- LICENSE
GENERALLY JUST HAVE A GENERAL
LICENSE BUT- I'DLIKE TO SEE
THAT THERE'S SOME ASPECT OF
REVIEW- THAT AND IT IS ON THE
NURSING SIDE OF THINGS I GOT ON
THE HEALTH PROFESSION SIDE OF.
ON THE SCHOOL HEALTH NURSING
SIDE OF THINGS TO BE SURE THAT
THOSE TYPES OF THOSE STANDARDS
ARE ARMED ARE MET BY THE END BY
THE EDUCATION PROGRAM ARE.
SYSTEM WHEN YOUR CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM THAT THOSE THAT THOSE
STANDARDS ARE MET I KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE THE C. T. C.
AVAILABLE TODAY AND THEY'RE NOT
ON THE LINE- BUT I AM ASSUMING
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE. SOME OF
THOSE- IT'LL LIKE CRITERIA WHEN
THEY'RE EVALUATING THE CAL
STATES RIGHT BECAUSE THEY
CURRENTLY APPROVE. THE SCHOOL
NURSE CREDENTIAL- BUT I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT PROCESS BUT-
THIS IS. HOW ARE STATE APPROVED
NURSE CREDENTIALS. YEAH I DID-
THE CTC- NO I BUT I MEAN YEAH I
THINK WE WOULD HAVE TO WORK ON
IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE THAT
PROCESS- EVALUATE IT- WE WOULD
HAVE TO WORK ON THAT. OKAY YET
NOW WOULD BE THAT WOULD APPLY
TO. THE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. INSTITUTIONS ALSO
RIGHT. BUT CITED FREESHIP THAT
AND- IT'S AND I ALSO WANNA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO HELP AND I DON'T TAKE UP TOO
MUCH TIME OR COMMITTEES I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING AND- I'M
GOING THAT MAYBE CAN HAVE A
DIALOGUE THOSE KENNEDY. SO AND-
BEFORE IT COMES TO THE FLOOR I
THINK IF WE CAN TO SATISFY THE
ISSUE ABOUT HOW TO JUST BE SURE
THAT WE VETS V. SO. BECAUSE
FINANCES OF THE SCHOOL DISCUSS
SELFISH EIGHT EIGHT ESSENTIALLY
PROGRAM AT SCHOOL DISTRICT AS A
SEAT YOU SEE IS THIS GOOD
ENOUGH RIGHT SO L. U. S. T. I
THINK THAT YEAH AS SOMEONE
WHO'S ACTUALLY SOUND
CREDENTIALS AND ACCREDITATION
BOARD. WE WILL BE SURE THE
REVIEW OF THAT IS NOT SIMPLY A
PAPER REVIEW WHICH AB SIDE.
THAT IT'S IT THERE'S AN
EXAMINATION OF THE- PREPARATION
AS WELL AND SO MY GUESS IS THAT
AGAIN I'M GETTING GAS BECAUSE
WE HAVE CITY SEE HERE IS THAT.
WHEN THEY WERE IT AT LEAST YOU
KNOW VARIOUS PROGRAM SETS AT
SAC STATE BECAUSE OF THE
FACULTY STRUCTURE AND SO FORTH
THERE IT'S FIGHT LESS NEED TO
GO INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL. ABOUT
THAT LIKE A BIT MORE OF A-
VERSUS IF WE KNOW. IT'S AN
HANDS OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHICH IS A EIGHTEEN IN
EDUCATIONAL. NORMALLY THE
PROPER OF NURSES RIGHT. AROUND
LIKE THESE THE SCS PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY NURSING SCHOOLS. THE
PERHAPS NEEDS TO BE PERHAPS A
LITTLE MORE ON THE GROUND
EXAMINATION REVIEW. RICHARD
DATE- THAT OF NURSES THAT GET
THIS CREDENTIAL- YOU DON'T MEET
THE STANDARDS AND THAT THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM. IS SUCH ON
THE NURSING SIDE OF THINGS I'M
NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE EDUCATION
SIDE OF THINGS. IS THE-
SUFFICIENT SO- AND DOES IT
BEYOND JUST SIMPLY LIKE A
WHITE. PICKED OFF THE VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS ON ON A PIECE OF
PAPER SO. PERHAPS WE CAN WORK
ON THAT HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
THAT THIS IS NOT THIS BILL IS
NOT CHANGING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS. OF OCCUR A SCHOOL
NURSE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM IT'S
CONTINUING TO DO WHAT THE STATE
ALREADY DOES. TO APPROVE ANY
SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIAL PROGRAM
ACROSS THE STATE. WHAT I THINK
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
YOU'RE BRINGING THAT I WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU ON AND
DISCUSS FURTHER ESPECIALLY WITH
YOUR EXPERTISE. IS ARE WE WHAT
STANDARDS ARE WE USING TO
APPROVE ANY SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM. YES AND SO
THAT'S THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS DOING. BUT IT IS I
THINK A VALID CONCERN AND- I
THINK SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
REVIEW TOGETHER AND- YES I
WOULD DEFINITELY LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT UP. ME TOO AND-
WELL I WON'T BILL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR CONVERSATIONS AND HOPEFULLY
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL ON THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU THANK OU BEFORE
YOU TO SENATOR MCGUIRE I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE SAME
STANDARD. AT FOUR C. ISSUE
PROGRAMS WOULD ALSO APPLY TO
ELLIE A PROGRAMS CORRECT YES
OKAY VERY GOOD. SENATE MCGUIRE.
YOU SO MUCH MANAGER BE VERY
QUICK WAS ACTUALLY THAT SAME.
IN THIS IS A AN ISSUE THAT WE
DISCUSSED. WITH SIX OF OUR
SEVEN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS THE VAST MAJORITY THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S. REPRESENT
RURAL COUNTIES IN WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN. A SCHOOL NURSES DEPLOYED
WITH LOCAL COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS LOCAL COUNTY PUBLIC
DEPARTMENT HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
HAVE BEEN SHORT ON PERSONNEL
SCHOOL NURSES HAVE CHIPPED IN
NOT JUST FOR STUDENT ACTING
CLINICS BUT FOR. TRADITIONAL
CLINICS INTO BEING ABLE TO GET
OUR NUMBERS UP AT THIS BILL IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED ESPECIALLY
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHY
I SUPPORT AND HARTLEY IN IN
HUMBLE COUNTY AT SUPPORTS THIS
BILL. ALONG WITH SUPERGENE
HUTCHINSON IN MENDOCINO
ASSEMBLY IN HARRISON DAHLE NOR
TO APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS KNOW
THAT. YOU CAN HAVE DISCUSSIONS.
WITH I'M TERRY PAYMENT YOU HAVE
GREAT RESPECT AND- THAT SOUNDS
GOOD AND THE BOTTOM LINE
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND THIS IS.
A DESPERATELY NEEDED BILL
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THIS.
YOU THANK YOU TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COME CONCERNS. WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
AB I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE- FOR THIS DISCUSSION
AND OF COURSE SENATOR PAN- FOR
OUR FUTURE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
WILL HAVE SHORTLY- YOU KNOW A
SINGLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WILL NOT SOLVE THE SCHOOL NURSE
SHORTAGE HOWEVER I'M CONFIDENT
THAT IF WE CONTINUE WORKING
TOGETHER WE CAN FIND INNOVATIVE
POLICY SOLUTIONS TO MITIGATE
THE SHORTAGE. OUR STUDENTS NEED
THAT FROM US AND THIS IS JUST A
START- IN WORKING TOWARDS THAT
GOAL- THIS BILL THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IT GIVES
OP SCHOOL NURSE CANDIDATES THE
OPTION WHICH OF WOULD THEY GET
THE SCHOOL NURSE CANDIDATES
STILL GET TO DECIDE WHICH
PROGRAM TO AND ROLAND- THIS
BILL IS NOT MANDATING THEM. TO
ENROLL IN AN ALLEY A SPONSORED
PROGRAM. SO IT GIVES THEM THAT
OPTION TO PURSUE- NECESSARY
CREDENTIALING WHERE THEY BEST
SEE FIT UP THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ASSEMBLY WOMAN OUR
MEMBERS TO HAVE A MOTION FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY MOVES THE BILL MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
EIGHT FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
OTOBO AYE A CHOI BOGUE HIGH
COURTESY. CURTIS THE AYE DELHI.
DELHI I GLAZER MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
AYE PAN. AND NOT VOTING. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL
FOR ONE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN
HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S OPEN THE ROLE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST
AND IF THE SERGEANTS KENDALL
LET. CENTER GLAZER KNOW THAT WE
ARE LOOKING CALLS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT MEDIC CONSULTANT PLEASE
PROCEED CONSENT. CHECK VOTING
ON A VICE CHAIR VOTING ON A THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO FOR
KATHY. COURTESY I DELI DELI I
REQUIRE APPROVAL PRIOR I. THANK
YOU THAT IS ALFA CONSENT OUT
COUNTERS OUT SEVEN ZERO WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO HELP FOUND
NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY TWO PLEASE
CALL OR CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE ZERO BUT CHOI
BOGUE FOR TROUBLED NOT VOTING
DELI DELI NOT VOTING GLAZER.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE ALRIGHT
WE'LL WAIT FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
EIGHT EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR FORTY NINE FIVE SURE
VOTING NO CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
TO. GLAZER MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE I
THINK YOU LEAVE THAT PHONE CALL
AS WELL V. TO OUR LAST BILL. I
THINK I REMEMBER IS NOT HERE SO
WE WAIT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH US SENATOR CORTESE
AND SENATOR MCGUIRE HAVE A
WONDERFUL REST OF THE DAY.
VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO ITEM ONE- MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB TWENTY TWO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. CHAIR VOTING HI FI
SURE NOT VOTING IN THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO A CHILL
VOGUE. TALLEY GLAZER. FOUR ZERO
THAT BILLS OUT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. EXCUSE ME FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
EIGHT EIGHT. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING NINE FIVE ST
VOTING NO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FORTY TWO. GLAZER THAT BILLS
OUT FORTY TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A FIGHTER PILOT IN
NUMBER FIVE AB EIGHT FIFTEEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND. AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
NINE FIVE SURE VOTING ON MY-
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
THAT BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM CONSULTANT
AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS. IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US I WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.